[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
abbas
[Musique]
elle
de l'homme en noir avait sur le plateau
de tout le monde en parle l'émission qui
parle avec nous ce soir ni chez voltaire
[Applaudissements]
et surtout la dent
bien rouge
m
jacques dutronc
le
au coeur du plomb seymour avant les
géniaux
[Applaudissements]
m
raison elle raconte l'irak et
l'afghanistan
[Musique]
plus
syrie et le retournement
mably
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ct ou la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière j'étais chez moi alors je me
suis fait chier grave
ah ouais ouais je préfère être là oui
franchement ouais quand même
il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup du mail pour
demander pourquoi tu n'étais pas là j'en
ai envoyé 800 s'agit sont arrivés tu
sais où j'étais sérieux
non je faisais un truc que j'avais déjà
fait c'est un truc qu'on n'a pas droit
de parler ici c'est quoi on n'a pas le
droit non pas un n'a pas mangé
recommencer à faire ce truc là et on n'a
pas le droit en appelant d'en parler
voilà tu va refaire le truc dont rouges
étaient tous les soirs avec un droit
d'en parler on n'a pas le droit non et
je ne sais ça va nous mener c'est au
même endroit que la latence je l'avais
fait ah ouais même top
[Musique]
et maintenant
on voit si jacques dutronc
bonsoir j'existe bon
bonsoir michel bédié qui est jackie et
michel
avant il y avait une différence qui
était beaucoup plus évidente c'est qu'il
avait les cheveux longs
je l'appelais jésus c'est vrai qu'il a
un côté jésus est maintenant loin
enfin bien alors vous êtes ici ce soir
pour un livre publié aux éditions du
seuil qui s'appelle dutronc la bio est
écrit par michel leydier alors vous
michel j'étais un passionné de un
passionné de jacques dutronc
vous l'avez rencontré dites-vous la
première fois vous aviez dix ans il y
avait 100 super 45 tours au pied du
sapin de noël
exact voilà c'est à versailles pour la
vie bah oui y'en a qui tombe dans
l'évangile et puis moi je suis tombé
dans du trou ouais et puis après sans
savoir que vous écririez un jour sur lui
vous avez conservé les les coupures de
presse les disques les vidéos vous êtes
devenu un 1 du trône au log le
personnage très tôt m'a fasciné par son
par sa dérision par son approche du
métier et sansan du tout pensé écrire un
jour un livre sur lui j'ai ouais j'ai
collectionné tous concernés alors vous
avez écrit d'abord un premier livre en
1999 sans le rencontrer
à l'époque il avait refusé de vous
rencontrer et puis trois ans plus tard
il vous le demande de faire une vidéo
promotionnelle pour un album qui
s'appelle madame l'existence et là vous
lui proposez vous en profiter une bio
c'était l'occasion rêvée
une fois que j'avais en face de moi donc
là je pouvais vraiment lui demander si
si ça m'intéresserait un jour de faire
ce livre dont je rêvais depuis longtemps
et à ma grande surprise j'ai toujours
pas compris pourquoi d'ailleurs il a dit
ok tout de suite je devais de bourg et
ouais c'est ça c'est non c'était pas ça
la met départ j'ai essayé de le
dissuader en lui expliquant que ni ma
famille ni mh le curé de la paroisse ne
m'avait [ __ ] fin et plus tout ça
raconte degrés il m'a dit non mais ça
ira quand même c'est vrai qu'on voit la
scène plutôt bien parce que c'est pas du
tout ce que j'avais envie d'explorer
ouais faut faire gaffe ici michel donc
jacques dutronc accepte contre toute
attente il vous invitant en corse et là
vous vous retrouvez à monticello alors
évidemment ce qui est très surprenant
tout de suite c'est la terrasse est
ainsi fournie en alcool que le bistrot
du coin qui mieux mieux mieux mieux y
arriver
c'est ainsi que c'est un bar qui ça
marche pas au diesel 1 c'est plutôt
formule 1
ouais ouais non non ça marche bien c'est
marrant ce bouquin non je l'étais avant
mais ça tombe bien c'est pour ça qu'ils
aient choisi
donc voilà on apprend dans ce livre
jacques que vous êtes né en 1943 dans
paris occupé par l'armée allemande la
nuit du 27 avril en est finalement vous
êtes parti dans un car de police enfin
votre mère est partie dans un car de
police et vous êtes né pratiquement dans
le cadre de prise par ce dernier dans le
hall en arrivons à la maternité mais je
crois que c'est ça alors on d'effacer vu
des jeunes aura plus pauvres et oui on
découvre donc très jeune jacques vous
avez une vraie passion pour les animaux
puisque l'appartement de vos parents au
67 rue de provence est encombré de
chiens de hamster de souris de
grenouilles de tortue et vous dites j'ai
toujours eu l'impression que je pouvais
mieux dialoguer s'est dit rien dire
puisque dialoguer pour dutronc c'est à
dire que je pouvais mieux dialoguer avec
les bestioles qu'avec les gens les
réponses sont inattendus la plupart du
temps chez les animaux voile sont aussi
plus franchement j'avais des tortues au
6 mai mais pas tous en même temps quand
il ya eu les 120 sourit il ya eu des
hamsters en même temps les tortues sté
plus tard ce que je faisais des courses
avec me remettais des numéros de fait je
ne savais pas qu'il fallait peindre les
carabins ne faut surtout pas d'ailleurs
parce qu'elle respire sûrement vers la
banque avait des numéros certaines
avaient des pattes cassées des choses
comme ça mais les souris c'était le je
crois le plus attractif pour les bonnes
femmes en tout cas vous étiez vraiment
un enfant gâté comme il avait de la
patience beaux parents mais pas henri
gratter chez pas gâteux sûrement mais
gâtés oui alors jeune déjà vous êtes
très original puisque vous restez par
exemple plusieurs mois sans vous l'avez
un pied oui d'ailleurs je vais vous le
montrer ce qui fait que le pied devient
noir comme du charbon comme une
chaussette de crasse et à ses
incroyables grigris rester totalement
imperméable
c'est tout lui 1 c'est vrai c'est à dire
dès le début finalement il est résigné
dans cette histoire pourquoi ils ne se
lavent pas un pied pourquoi pas deux
mais par contre je ne sais plus c'était
le gourou miroir c'est plus je ne sais
plus alors ensuite vous avez une maladie
la maladie de buyo c'est-à-dire cdd des
rhumatismes articulaires plus de la
fièvre et là un petit peu comme beaucoup
de gens que nous recevant dans cette
émission laurent pendant la
convalescence
jake se met à la guitare c'est à ces
moments là c'est la vocation c'est comme
julio iglesias et comme des tas de gens
que possible a dit au wall arc s il faut
dit il pour la maladie
son séjour prolongé dans le lit pour se
mettre à la guitare et vous deviendra un
bon guitariste un méga longer manon
structure alors c'est un livre très haut
pour moi ça m'a beaucoup touché parce
que les gens dont on parle évidemment
c'est yahia la bande de la trinité alors
il ya eddy calafat jean-pierre huster le
frère de francis huster jean philippe
smet qui deviendra johnny hallyday
claude moine qui deviendra eddy mitchell
et tout le monde en s'aimant quand même
qu'il y ait eu à cet endroit là à ce
moment là une telle concentration de
futures stars c'est la bande de la
trinité c'est quelque chose de
surnaturel
non mais c'était bien la trinité puis
avec gainsbourg au site était là il y
aurait pas loin avant lui il allait
aussi l'école communale de la rue
blanche arrêtée
et là vous commencez à composer la
première chanson que vous composez c'est
un énorme tube
j'irai quand
penseur
[Musique]
au début c'était un instrumental qui
s'appelait fort chabrol que jouer les
fantômes et françoise entendu ça diallo
là je me chantait ça je ne sais pas faux
fait remettre des paroles et voilà et
après vous rentrez dans la dans la
carrière parce que quand jean philippe
smet et est signé chez vol par jacques
wolfsohn et devient johnny hallyday vous
dit pourquoi pas nous et là vous faites
partie d'un groupe qui s'appelle el toro
les six tonale taureau c'est pas vous
hein ah non non non non et je dors cette
année elle devrait vous vous êtes un des
cyclones vous êtes allé un des
guitaristes du groupe et vous commencé
comme ça jouer à faire des tournées et
là une histoire absolument
extraordinaire c'est qu'un jour fait une
tournée en première partie d'un
clarinettiste qui s'appelle andré révéle
yachting et un jour ce type vous dit tu
sais tu as une tête de curés et vous
vous lui dites patience mon fils tu vas
bientôt mourir est mort trois jours plus
tard il est mort le mettre dans un
accident dans la sueur et qu'est ce que
tu vois pour nos cabines un vrai don de
voyance à tout va bien mais le
sonorisateur l'acquis qui part à
bordeaux dans sa porsche et voulzy tu
vas prendre feu et sa caisse prend feu
sur la route c'est vrai comme un piri sa
porsche deux fois quand même ils sont
fils aussi à l'école
ouais je lis ton fils va bien c'est vrai
beaucoup il ya l'école j'ai dit bah
appelle ça m'étonnerait il doit être
couvert de boutons effectivement il est
appelé dans l'énigme et votre fils est
rentré il est rouge face pourquoi il est
totalement malade mais au bout d'un
certain nombre je crois que ça s'arrête
maintenant ça va là j'avais pas ça qu'il
était voyant jacques dutronc jeux
précités sa femme qui était là dedans
bah oui tu vois les seuils de dialoguer
mais elle sait les astres et lui c'est
les flashs
voilà alors vous découvrez l'alcool à
l'armée au retour de l'armée vous
devenez l'assistant de jacobson vous
rencontré françoise hardy et là vous
annulez votre mariage aux assez
incroyable fait partie de ces gens qui
sont capables
c'est tout était prêt quoi les bancs
étaient publiés la table était mise
le couvert au lieu de dire oui j'ai dit
non mais avant j'ai eu la correction de
dire non la veille où il ya des gens qui
disent non trente ans après s'être
mariés vous vous avez vous l'a dit avant
oui puis avant de l'avant le maire et
avant le curiste j'ai dit non d'après le
temps de commander le traiteur amis et
pas de traiteur et qu'est ce qu'elle est
devenue ghislaine elle attend toujours
aller à l'église
je ne je ne pense pas je crois que
commence à perdre il a dit qu'à la fat
le rencontrer je crois qu'elle est
mariée là des enfants et tout va très
bien là tout va très bien au contraire
bon c'est a eu en effet d'annuler ça
comme ça c'est à dire j'ai très mal
dormi cette nuit-là
[Applaudissements]
je devrai voyez donc les autres nuits
elle c'est vraiment une voyance du tout
la vie en couple à ghislaine sauf que là
je ne savais pas à l'époque mais quand
même
voilà mais ce qui est drôle c'est qu'il
est allé donc voir les beaux parents
pour leur expliquer et se sont gaussés à
ce qu'il est drôle il ne croyait pas un
mot qu aurait alors un jour il ya une
séance chez vogue pour un chanteur qui
s'appelle benjamin et là pendant une
pause vous commencé à chanter et on
découvre que vous êtes un excellent
chanteur j'aime bien bah oui bah oui
tout le monde trouve tout le monde s'en
aperçoit vous sentant yaourt quoi
n'importe comment c'est à dire oui donc
mais je chantais pas spécialement du
yaourt puisque wolson faisait faire des
chansons pour combattre van thuan ou je
ne sais quoi là et voilà c'est à dire
que c'était l'époque où c'était la mode
de bob dylan van thuân la chanson
engagée
wolson jacobson le directeur artistique
demande des chansons à jacques lanzmann
et du tronc invente la chanson dégagé je
trouve que le terme est très bien choisi
je sais pas s'il est de vous mon cher
leydier je ne sais plus mais en tous les
cas c'est bien alors exemple de chansons
dégagé dj
noah est mort
ap
des cadeaux
si force des jeux
petit
[Musique]
hu
m
je suis
[Musique]
oh
rien
[Musique]
m
le monde entier est à la cus qui lève
c
[Musique]
déjà
lavallée
en palestine
papa lui
[Musique]
je me lévy chez castel
je me
je
il y aura dedans
tête il est 5 heures
paris
c'est l'oeil des massifs et bazana
strauss kahn est à cheval sur mobile
n'est pas témoin dans les plus
importants qu'est ce que t'as roversi
fermé
vous
vaste là
je suis pour
je suis mon noeud
jamais
je suis un homme
je suis un gentil
[Musique]
3 v
les jeux
donc l'année
il
au travail
je vais d'abord d'abord c'était
déjà
puissante elle
metropolit heures
il est sympa et attirance mais méfiez
vous c'est intrigant c'est le plus grand
des vols
mais cet homme
puisque vous partez en voyage
plus jeune ou
quittant ce soir voilà jacques dutronc
alors tout le tout le début de la
carrière de jacques dutronc les allées
vogue sont concentrés dans sept cd qu'on
trouve dans ce superbe emballages en
forme de cas qu'il soit là c'est
extraordinaire
les inédits il ya des trucs absolument
incroyable il ya ça il ya ça c'est
introuvable restés introuvables ailleurs
les boys des professions destine aux
sports cardin calzado sports karine
[Musique]
et ça ne fait
la fantasia
or on sait qu'à venir aux mains elles
sont là
j'écris
jours
v
[Applaudissements]
bonjour territoire
superior mégane
conrad marque red bull
jacques dutronc espagnol l'ofsp les bras
donc énorme quoi c'est à dire qu'en plus
tout ce qu'on vient d'entendre je crois
vous avez composé 98% des musiques vous
avez collaboré aux paroles quoi suez
méfie beaucoup de talent peut-être pas
si faux que je vois je vois non il ya
très peu de gens en france il ya très
peu de mélodiste comme ça il ya quinze
jours évidemment qu'à composer mélodies
extraordinaire julien clerc mais c'est
rarissime le nombre de chansons que vous
avez écrites quand on les entendait tout
comme ça elles sont bien en plus ça veut
dire c'est facilement comparable à ce
que les anglo saxons à l'époque oui
d'ailleurs je les cite moi j'étais mais
bravo merci nos prix
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi je te félicite
en plus ce musée et j'étais même très
étonnés l'époque j'étais même classé sur
radio caravane sur la piste et radio
radio et sur un bâton l'inclusivité d'un
bateau avant j'étais très étonnée des
normes et c'est aussi bien que les kings
sont les laitues tous ces groupes
quand vous recevez votre premier disque
d'or vous allez le vendre c'est ça
résume tout ça je vais essayer ouais
c'est de découvrir qu'il est en cuivre
en fait bon non c'est du jaune trompette
comme on dit c'est pas du frij ans et
c'était du jaune trompette le bijoutier
me faire c'est de la merde je les
gardais vail non mais pourquoi audi dont
je leur ai jamais entendu il est disque
de platine c'était quoi en vrai c'est de
la merde
quelle bande d'enculés m
alors en fait lanzmann signe les textes
dans vos chansons mais vous y vous y
participe énormément et c'est à cause de
ça que vous avez des problèmes avec lui
plus tard non non n'y a jamais eu de
vraie fâcherie fâché ne s'est jamais mis
sur la gueule contrairement avec
d'autres moins non mais par exemple
quand vous vous avez voulu interviewer
lanzmann pour pour la biographie de
jacques n'a pas été possible
non c'est une scène qui a refusé non
c'est pas d'un droit il a le droit de
refuser si je peux me permettre moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il est en tant
qu'artiste parce que c'est aussi un
artiste challenge mais il a un ego qui a
sa place et il aimerait bien que qu'on
lui dise c'est formidable ce que tu fais
mais maintenant que je connais un petit
peu jacques je sais que c'est le genre
de mots qui peut pas sortir de sa bouche
il est manifeste son contentement ou sa
satisfaction d'une manière beaucoup plus
subtil que ça non mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya des choses bizarres chez lansman vous
citez d'ailleurs dans la baleine blanche
qui était en redemande
jacques lanzmann il ya un chanteur qui
se fait faire une pipe par une fille qui
est la fille de la concierge du studio
en vue des elfes et des pipe aux autres
musiciens dix ans mais on la retrouve
suicider et la façon dont s'est racontée
par lanzmann dans ce bouquin on a
vraiment l'impression que
c'est arrivé quoique il a fallu filer
plein de pognon à la à la mer à la
concierge du studio pour calais pour
elle la ferme
le chanteur en question s'appelle bobby
laser il chante des chansons du genre
jeu plaît aux filles enfin bon quelque
chose de très proche des playboy ou deux
j'aime les filles et
et tous le nom d'imprésario très voisin
de ronson était bon tous les personnages
sont là sur la table
et effectivement il arrive des choses
donc où s'arrête la fiction alors c'est
un petit peu effectivement ouais ouais
vous aurait bien aimé se faisait poser
la question alors je vois arriver mais
voilà le belge est la question
je ressemble au règlement de compte quoi
qu'il ya eu qu'il ya moins de l'histoire
quand même dans les studios mais il
aurait sa personne et
non mais je sers dit je vais faire même
si j'ai quand même joué jeux interdits
dans les chiottes du studio ce qu'elle à
la gonzesse qui voulais être chanteuse
10ème et c'est là le je suis dit c'est
là qu'on enregistre et donc je jouais
aux interdits jamais mets toi à l'aise
d'enquêter sur les chiottes et je vous
interdis mais c'est bizarre genthod
rires effectivement celle du barça
arrive sinon je vois que ça que si une
fois il ya une femme assez assez
élégante qui s'est présentée je suis
questionnée fameux difficile à la
fiancée de l'ingénieur du son d'andré
bernot et voilà je fais je chante et je
lui dis les pales actuellement il doit
être en face aux canaris en train de
prendre un café et lui il y revient
l'été nu sur le piano avec une casserole
quand même sur la tête
voilà donc c'est quand même plus drôle
que le racontait le faisais des pipes à
tout le monde pas qu elle s'est suicidée
vous chez moi non c'est vrai ceci dit
les romanciers jacquot donc pourquoi pas
mais enfin c'est pas très cool quand
même ouais ouais voilà ce qui est encore
plus extraordinaire c'est qu'après avoir
fait toutes ces chansons avoir connu ce
succès un jour vous en avez marre vous
arrêter vous commencez à faire du cinéma
il faut que jean marie périer vous
forcent un peu pour faire antoine et et
sébastien et et vous redevenez une
grosse vedette du cinéma
maintenant c'est incroyable et des gens
qui essayaient toutes leurs vies des
vedettes de la chanson ou du cinéma vous
donnez veulent être des 200 sans donner
l'impression que vous donnez du mal quoi
on s'en donne toujours tout fait selon
vous en fais donc ça revient au même
alors on apprend aussi dans ce livre un
certain nombre de choses sur la vie
conjugale de jacques et françoise et
c'était assez sans complaisance je
voulais vous féliciter michel puisque ce
soir je distribue un petit peu les
félicitations
je trouve que vraiment c'est pas du tout
un géographique etc c'est très clair
enfin c'est vrai que c'était
parfois on a envie de se dire bon de
gomme et peut-être les aspérités
mais non j'ai essayé de ne pas le faire
en tout cas la remercie le souligner
alors voilà donc c'est une histoire
d'amour effectivement assez assez
étrange puisque françoise dit jacques
m'adresser à la solitude quand un jour
jean marie périer vous dit tu déconnes
veut boudier françoise dans tout ça vous
répondez elle c'est différent je laime
vous avez préféré tromper d'abord et
être fidèle ensuite alors qu'elle
pensait que dans la vie on était d'abord
filiales et ont trompé après vous
n'étiez pas sur la même longueur d'onde
maintenant d'avis et j'ai fais comme ça
vient c'est pas malheureux mais je crois
qu'elle aime la solitude aussi tout le
monde l'est de toute façon la salle
fâche si on peut la choisir
oui voilà
elle a dit un jour tout ça ne me fera
plus ni chaud ni froid
et c'est ce qui a fini par arriver elle
a eu de la passion pour vous très
longtemps françoise à redire mais je
l'avait envoûté
ouais mais non mais je les oublie que je
réponds ça oui bah aussi sûrement mais à
l'époque quand même c'est un peu trop
pudique peut-être voulu montriez pas
assez haut
alors si je vais montrer souvent acheté
hier j'étais n'y est pas chaque fois ça
une chambre pour vous vous dites c'est
un petit peu la cerise sur le gâteau
quoi y avait rigolé avec les potes vous
saviez qui avait françoise vous
regrettez sérieux jacques non à bâle
aussi si j'ai fait de la peine a déjà
envie je peux regretter mais sinon
contraire j'aurais dû faire pire pour
faire de la peine gratuitement c'est un
peu comme quoi c'est un enfant gâté en
fait un beau gosse à qui tout a réussi
non bah ouais je m'excuse fallon dit pas
je me suis excusé moi vous avez jamais
été tentée par le divorce n'ont pas
n'ont ni le mariage ni le divorce
pas plus dans l'arène parle vous me
direz oui m'enfin on s'est quand même
mari et françoise besson s'est marié
c'était pour des vins et papiers je ne
sais quoi faire
moi piste est pas mal oui vous avez fini
par vous marier en 81 oui le c'était
juste la veille du 1er avril
il raconte dans le bocal à la nuit de
noce pas acheter le vous verrez c'est
françoise qui me l'a raconté donc le
huawei
elle était alors à la fin du livre
il ya une question que michel leydier
pose un certain nombre de vos proches en
demandant est ce que vous croyez que
jacques est heureux et françoise répond
il ne m'a pas donné souvent l'impression
d'être heureux vous avez été heureux
sûrement mais il n'en suis pas toujours
rendu compte
c'est la gueule de bois
[Musique]
alors jacques dutronc est ce que comme
tous les garçons et les filles de votre
âge elle est un peu fatiguée là pourquoi
pas ce qu'on va faire une interview tous
les garçons et les filles
est ce que comme tous les garçons les
filles de votre âge vous regarder des
chiffres et des lettres
non est ce que comme tous les garçons et
filles de votre âge vous pensez qu'il ya
plus de jeunesse et impliquent printemps
surtout même way ainsi comme tous les
garçons et les filles de votre âge
d'être attiré par le bouddhisme
non non c'est trop grave et c'est comme
tous les garçons les filles votre âge
vous portez du thermolactyl de damart
non ça sent mauvais est ce que comme
tous les garçons les filles votre âge
politiquement vous avez viré à droite
j'ai mis mon clignotant à gauche
est ce que comme tous les garçons les
filles votre âge vous appeler les flics
quand les jeunes font trop de bruit
sûrement pas est ce que comme tous les
garçons les filles de votre âge vous
avez peur de mourir
oui enfin ça pour être un peu plus
longue la réponse mais cela et je suis
comme tous les garçons et les filles de
votre âge vous surveillez votre taux de
cholestérol nam nam n'y a aucun problème
de cholestérol
tout est très bon est ce que comme tous
les garçons et les filles de votre âge
vous êtes susceptibles quand on vous
parle de votre âge
non parce que ça se voit pas tellement
est ce que comme tous les garçons et les
filles de votre âge vous dormez devant
votre télé le samedi soir non
javier drolas bio aux éditions du seuil
[Musique]
et ma peau
voici michel drucker
michel drucker très heureux de vous
avoir michel tellement heureux d'être
assis à côté de lui pour plein de
raisons
ça a été notre premier invité non or
selon d'histoire ça fait presque
quarante ans jour pour jour qu'on a
débuté ensemble devant les quais mais
inspire aux dés sociale crosms là
c'était à doué il y avait deux jeunes
mis en cause mao qui revenait d'une
mauvaise passe et qui chantait le noir
c'est noir c'est noir il y avait lui qui
devait chanter moi et moi il y avait un
gars qui ressemblait comme deux gouttes
à françoise sagan gaieté polnareff
depuis y avait de la danel qui sortaient
les neiges du kilimandjaro menti il y
avait les sharks qui vient avec la
yamaha mec qui s'appelle jean claude
petit 1
excusez du peu près ça à 40 ans johnny
se demander s'il refait surface
toi tu ne te demander rien de normal tu
te souviens qu'ils avaient une panthère
à des fonds non les visites mensuelles
de toute ma vie on est rentré avec
johnny et jeune fille me disait ce que
tu crois que j'ai reçue à surface et g10
et toute façon la vitesse à laquelle tu
vas on va jamais à faire surface tous
les deux ans voilà merci maintenir alors
en tous les cas nous il n'ya pas 40 ans
qu'on se connaît michel ça fait une
vingtaine d'années qu'on se croise dans
le métier et puis y'a pas longtemps
l'année dernière j'ai organisé à un
repas chez moi au 93 rue du faubourg
saint-honoré et il y avait plein de
l'animateur comme ça qu'ils essayer
d'exister parce qu'on a tous sont égaux
gros comme une maison
et puis au bout d'un moment le calme
s'est installé autour de la table et la
voix de michel est resté j'ai découvert
ce soir là en fait que vous étiez le
le parrain quoi le godfather sa fille un
coup de vieux sages n'ont pas du tout
pourquoi il ya des jeunes par la mafia
[Applaudissements]
alors en suisse et que j'étais simple
glissement elle a été voir papadia alors
ensuite on a débarqué tous les deux en
normandie effectivement on a en a seront
peut le dire quand je crois qu'on a
sauvé la france on a cela de vie c'était
un grand souvenir parce qu'il fallait
être gonflé merci quand même à notre
patron christopher baldelli et nous
laisser faire toute la nuit ensemble à
lille en direct tous les deux oui et ça
a marché non plus voilà c'était pas
évident de samedi soir tu vois dutronc
moi aussi j'ai des souvenirs d'anciens
combattants avec drucker maintenant je
suis heureux de vous recevoir michèle
aujourd'hui même pas heureux dit la
vérité
j'aimerais de vous recevoir michèle
parce que c'est les 40 ans de france 2
lundi
voilà lundi donc et vous ça fait 40 ans
que vous faites de la télévision alors
il ya une grande émission qui est
diffusée lundi soir à 20h50 consacré aux
40 ans de la chaîne
on va regarder la bande annonce je vais
regarder votre caméra et vous allez dire
magnéto serge magnéto serge cals fans
vous allez assister premiers programmes
diffusés par la seconde chaîne de
télévision de l'universel lundi soir
france des souffle ses 40 bougies et
voit sa vie défiler devant vous qu'on
était tous des personnages différents
ces émissions cultes ses animateurs
faire et surtout ses grands moments
d'émotion un moment magique
une soirée exceptionnelle pour
feuilleter l'album d'une toute jeune
quadra se taper votre album il ya des
émissions oublier un coin d'ombré
apparaissent
j'ai toujours été extrêmement libre sur
cette chaîne lundi soir michel drucker
et jean luc delarue fait les quarante
ans d'une chaîne pas comme les autres
fois
à 20h50 sur france 2
alors nous seuls il est génial
génériques il a été composé par jean
pierre bouteyre et jean claude petit les
voilà toujours jean-claude petit studio
alors dans cette émission michel tu
interview les autres donc on s'est dit
avec catherine barma
c'est quand même con que lui on
l'interview pas donc on a décidé de
l'inviter ce soir c'est la première fois
alors ta carrière michel se déroule sur
plusieurs générations sur plusieurs
décennies sur quatre décennies
exactement sur plusieurs septennat voilà
et oui et tu dis je suis le plus jeune
des ancien et le plus ancien des jeunes
dire qu'en fait tu as connu l'époque de
l'après guerre c'était la télévision là
la fin la télévision en noir et blanc de
lula tf et tu es toujours là en dehors
en 2004 tu dis l'histoire de la télé
c'est l'histoire de ma vie
et oui parce que moi je suis rentré en
1964 par hasard j'y suis encore qui est
miraculeux est souvent dit mais comment
tu fais pour être encore là et pourquoi
mais je dis parce que lorsque j'ai
commencé dans ce métier j'ai voulu le
faire toute ma vie mon père était
médecin il n'a pas fait médecine pour le
faire pendant cinq ans quand tu as
commencé c'était cognac gct zitrone qui
était l'homme à tout faire de zitrone et
il travaillait avec zitrone de 7 heures
du matin à minuit
je bossais aux sports et puis je faisais
un petit peu des heures supplémentaires
avec lui je lui conduit sa voiture
souvent je le faisais souvent dans le
détail mais je dis ici donnant souvent
je faisais même répété les casaques du
caire devant les contre-allée de
l'avenue bosquet sa femme de donner un
torchon il avait atteinte au pluralisme
et à droite de la voiture
il mangeait ce qu'avaient préparé sa
femme qui a été débordé moi je lisais
casaque verte au khroub et les gens nous
voyaient hébété avec la beuh et de la
voiture ils vérifient moi j'étais
inconnu citron est une immense star
qu'on n'imagine pas il y avait deux
goals gabin morgant et et lui dans les
sondages
et puis visiteront de répondre aux
téléspectateurs dans la rue g et ceux ci
seront ils leur disaient ne l'approchez
pas je vous assure que je suis une
personne privée je vous interdis demeure
conner il était j'étais terrifié il
était très méchant dans citroni les îles
étaient impitoyables en dehors de son
travail il ne voulait pas qu'on emmerde
dans sa vie personnelle sauf que
lorsqu'on fait un métier public
vous en savez tous les quelque chose il
faut la cour bien
l'avion dans un train ce qui te dit je
vous aime beaucoup c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement dur et qui avait plutôt
tendance à caresser les ministres en
place dans le saint graal ce qui
déplaisait de terriblement à claude
darget voilà alors il y avait claude
darget zitrone d'aller remplacer claude
dargent et que darget tu vous racontez
lui lui lui lui offrait chaque année du
cirage
oui et un gilet rayé de nestor et c'est
moi qui aie l'acheter en plus mouais
c'est à dire que d'art j'ai détesté it
ronde ils le détestent tellement qu'ils
avaient dressé son chien pour qu'il
aille pisser sur la porte de chez moi
qui aimais déjà beaucoup des chiens j'ai
beaucoup contribué au dressage et un
jour larsson il s'appelle l'art sous le
chien il est descendu son plateau du
journal et on a vu se diriger alors que
jointes et comment ces épices et sur les
petites routes en direct pendant le
journal
j'aurais tellement voulu que le
caméraman baisse un peu pour voir les
onze itron de secouer sa jambe pendant
que le chien de large et l'élu a reçu
pas tant ils se détestaient cordialement
il avait un grand talent tous les deux
ouais tu te souviennes d'arz et j'ai
bien sûr je parle comme un vieux
vraiment tête souvient nazaire mais t'as
bongo soit entre la vie des animaux
frédéric rossif enfin la vie des animaux
oui il commentait le tennis et c'est un
mec formidable
ce qui est incroyable c'est que toi tu
as fait grève en 68 et j'étais viré tant
d'autres ne connais pas supporté que sa
télévision se mettent en grève
donc il a aligné tous les mecs connu
zitrone d'art j'échappe à deux coups des
attirions alors moi j'ai été le dernier
joueur 25 26 ans j'ai trinquet aussi
parce que je présentais déjà l'émission
de variétés que michal ardo et j'ai cru
que j'allais disparaître parce que
imaginer je sais pas moi de la rue où
arthur ou nagui ou la nouvelle
génération qui est déjà en place et
qu'on vire au boutiste de 7 ans - alors
qu'on est en pleine ascension
j'ai cru que je m'en remettrai jamais
mais sam a été extrêmement utile car
j'ai découvert vraiment qu'on n'était
pas des stars ouais à l'époque quand on
s'est fait lourder on était persuadé que
la france descend dans la rue pour nous
sauver itron de penser qu'il y aura une
grève vrai on veut zitrone niet mouais
moi on m'appelait maurice brugger au
bout de six mois alors j'étais souvent
dit à michel que ma femme tu appelles
terminator béatrice elle dit est dit
drucker c'est terminator parce que
terminator c'est celui qui est toujours
vivant à la fin du film c'est terminator
mais c'est un terminator qui a failli
tomber plusieurs fois ouais parce que ce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est que j'ai pris
quelques gamelles mai 68 c'était très
douloureux mais j'ai failli sauter
souvent il ya ya ya eu l'histoire moi je
me souviens parce que j'étais j'étais là
c'est l'époque de philippe guillôme moi
il m'a fait un truc incroyable j'étais
là depuis huit ans je faisais
champs-elysées il vient déjeuner chez
moi quand on est en fin de contrat la
télévision je sais pas comment ça se
passe dans le disque en général mamadou
on donne une idée pareille attitude in
avec le grand patron si c'est chez toi
tu dis tiens il vient chez moi c'est
bien ma femme est jamais la semaine
jamais de ça on est en tête à tête et au
moment elle ouvre la porte pour servir
le café et longtemps le patron de
l'époque me dire juste ce bout de phrase
de toute façon michel la télévision de
demain ne passera pas par vous croates
dont champs elysées champs elysées c'est
fini moi je prends ça sur la tête avec
43 44 ans elle referme la porte je le
raccompagne à l'ascenseur et là il m'a
somme pour le compte
écoutez j'écoutais donc je vais à l'être
sur l'a5 puisque on me demande d'aller
sur l'a5 désespérément ou sur la une de
deux chez bouygues et je voudrais rester
en service public parce que c'est ma
famille j'y suis quand même depuis très
longtemps et là il me dit non non vous
n'avez pas compris
vous allez continuer champs elysées
pendant un an mais vous allez former un
jeune troll
ah oui c'est dire qu'il a refermé sa
soeur et je suis rentré chez moi au
salon ma femme d'action est vrai c'est
pas loin vu en âge et je partais le soir
avec depardieu pour faire un champ
elysées à new york et je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie je raconte ça
il me dit chapeau file un coup de boule
de sa voisine on le fait bien en vie il
me dit et fait nous de finesse et juste
décroché le téléphone g1 plus dominique
cantien j'étudie à francis bruit que
c'est d'accord lundi chez les jeunes et
et 24 ans après je les sentais pas là
pour faire stars 90 m mais mais mais
c'est vrai que bon c'était pas de gaieté
de coeur l'émission était difficile
c'est une mission qui était un lundi
soir une émission de variétés y avait
beaucoup de filles qui suivait la
cinquième édition d'arrêter le mercredi
il y en avait une de vendredi et le
samedi
j'ai tenu quatre ans mais quatre ans
assez confortable parce que rendons-leur
cette justice avait été engagée par
bouygues le lay mougeotte était
extrêmement réglo j'ai fait ce que j'ai
voulu mais il était temps que je parte
alors tu aurais fait quoi imagine que
bon
guilaume veut plus de toi imagine que ça
marchera sur tf1 mais tu aurais fait
quoi j'aurais fait de la radio sans
doute
et puis j'aurais fait ce que tu as fais
toi pendant trois ou quatre ans genre
attendu oui que l'argent que la chambre
par dias heures mais j'ai été sonné
alors c'est quand même un obsédé de la
durée at risk it intéresse c'est dur et
d'ailleurs avec ta femme ça ça durera
vous êtes marié avec dennis aval depuis
1973 et puis je l'exploit dans votre
jardin c'est énorme ça fait quand même
pas mal d'années alors elle avant d'être
mariée avec toi elle était mariée que
maurice jarre mais père de jean-michel
jarre qui est couvert d'oscars
il est le papa de stefanik voilà c'est
un peu comme afrique et donc toi quand
tu as épousé dany non seulement il
fallait qu'il fasse aussi bien que son
premier mari qui était couvert d'oscars
mais en plus que tu fasse plaisir à ta
mère qui trouvait quand même que bon
animateur télé c'est quand même pas
génial donc toute ta vie tu as eu cette
pression quand même un animateur télé ma
mère trouvé ça nul puisque elle avait 3
bible ouais chancelle
télérama le monde ouais et me disais
toujours et me disait toujours
c'est dommage parce que pour une fois à
télérama enfin consacré sa une
ils ont mis 35 ans elle n'était pas là
pour le voir enfin bref et quand
j'arrivais le soir le dimanche je voyais
télérama le monde et collectionner tous
des éditoriaux de jean-daniel lundi
maryse du v60 est rentré cibler ce
qu'elle considérait que le grand
échiquier c'était beaucoup mieux que
champs elysées et que rostropovitch
était bien une règle
mathieu s'était moins bien ouais alors
dit moi dani et toi on vous voit jamais
ensemble très peu comment ça se fait
parce que moi j'ai la chance d'avoir une
épouse qui a pas ou il exister car elle
a existé bien avant moi ouais elle a un
univers elle dans lequel elle est très
heureuse
on vit beaucoup en province à la une
passion c'est pas triste mais lui et lui
qui a 50 ça il sait ce que c'est que
d'avoir 25 chiens et et puis en réalité
elle fait partie d'une catégorie de
femmes assez rare mais je suis sûr que
béatrice ardisson me comprendra qui est
assez fier du succès de son maître c'est
à dire quand je pars le matin depuis 30
ans j'ai l'impression qu'on me dit aller
franco cartable n'oublie pas ton 4h et
ramène moi de bonnes notes mais elle est
assez contente de ces deux sons mais
qu'est ce qui est assez rare et puis
vous avez un compte joint ça joue aussi
elle voit bien qu'elle a du pognon qui
rendra les valeurs et alors il a pas il
a raison de dire ça quand je l'aï
rencontré j'étais fauché tu été fauchée
j'habitais ce zèle je dise pas possible
donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé également
il n'y a rien de bien sûr si bien ce
d'habiter chez sa femme quand quand elle
économiquement faibles des deux ouais
c'est pas cette arrivée puis le sens mal
dis donc j'ai beaucoup bossé pour ça
aussi jack vous avez un compte joint
avec françoise vous non non non non il
n'a pas même pas le lit mais toi alors
on apprendre dans le livre tu son livre
on apprend dans le bouquin qu'en fait
lui c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pas la
fourmi en ce moment la cigale l'ua et la
wii dilapide il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
points communs entre françoise hardy et
jacques et derniers mois c'est que aucun
des deux ne bouffent l'oxygène de l'eau
train et qu'on respecte chacun nos
passions et nous prennent aux potes et
nos amis alors dany saval et ce qu'elle
aime la natation
non est ce qu'elle aime le vélo rien du
tout est ce qu'elle aime l'hélico non
est-ce qu'elle supporte la nervosité
anxiété
elle est assez contente quand je me
casse le matin quand je reviens tard le
soir
ouais je suis assez fatigant pour
l'entourage je suis comme toi je bosse
tout le temps et elle dit quoi quand tu
téléphones en dînant par exemple
elle fait plus attention mais là où elle
me regarde bizarrement c'est quand
justement de votre réfrigérateur est
bien la même place depuis 30 ans on est
d'accord alors la télévision a évolué
évidemment depuis 40 ans en vingt ans
par exemple on est passé du mieux disant
culturel de françois léotard quand il a
été question de vendre tf1 à wimmis de
la culture de l'époque voilà donc le
mieux disant culturel
tf1 est aujourd'hui c'est patrick le lay
qui dit nous vendons du temps de cerveau
disponible à coca cola moi j'ai passé
quatre ans sur tf1
et c'était la règle était déjà limpide
quand je veux dire la grande différence
entre une chaîne commerciale le service
public c'est que ils peuvent pas d'états
d'âme
il faut que la pub rentre alors de là à
dire qu'une émission est bonne parce
qu'elle a fait 35% de parts de marché 6
millions elle est mauvaise il a fait
moins alors là c'est un vaste débat
parce que si on va jusqu'au bout on peut
penser que taxi lien est un meilleur
film que le pianiste sur la liste de
schindler et n'importe quel journal as
quand elle est amère journal que le
monde c'est évidemment faune et la fini
de rigoler jacques je crois que c'est
une fonction pause cherche et la fille
d'elliot ça va s'arrêter et n'a fini de
rigoler pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi fini de rigoler sur une chaîne
commerciale
il suffit pas de faire beaucoup
d'audience part de marché encore faut-il
que l'audience correspondent à la cie
brin publicitaire que tu veux toucher en
l'occurrence la sainte la célèbre
ménagères de moins de 50 ans tu es tu
appelles dans le privé jacent sierre
c'est quoi ça ça c'est très simple voilà
quand on entend à la radio par exemple
exemple j'aime on dit sur europe 1 tous
les matins vers 10h30 j'entends voici
les scores de la veille qui a également
alors intel a fait 30 % de parts de
marché et 3 millions de téléspectateurs
l'autre il faut expliquer ce que c'est
les gens combien de rien ça c'est très
simple quand vous faites 30% de parts de
marché ou un peu plus c'est le cas de ce
que fait tirer régulièrement à manger
indices japonais de cheval et la télé
comment ça me passionne les gens l'ont
jamais vu ça je crois que c'est la
première carte a demandé la permission à
médiamétrie j'imagine à jacqueline
aglietta
voilà un très bon alors voilà ce qui se
passe 30% parts de marché ça veut dire
que sur 100 téléspectateurs
il y en a trente qui vous ont regardé et
ça représente combien ça quel public
là ça représente peut-être cinq six sept
ou huit points 1 point d'audience
correspond à 530 mille téléspectateurs à
l'aja quand par exemple thierry fait 4
points d'audience
il fait deux millions et demi
téléspectateurs quand il fait 30 %
d'audience ça veut dire qu'à cette
heure-là il ya trente spectateurs sur
100 qui le regardaient la teda corps
pour dire que l'on en perles
non je crois pas ok on verra on verra
quand mais mais mais on peut faire sans
une télévision de masse 5 millions de
téléspectateurs et 40% dans un marché
qui est une fausse bonne audience parce
qu'elles touchent pas la cible qu'on
veut toucher la fameuse ménagère
heureusement dans le service public on
peut encore montrer aux gens ce qu'ils
aiment et ce qu'ils pourraient aimer
devra émettre de la culture ses
sensations et toujours là tu me rend
vraiment justice en disant que
champs-elysées et il portait des
missions culturellement très vite
voilà ma logique là j'ai pris une
évidence mon émission puisque les bras
le corps les cours des autres je connais
pas les coupes des hommes regardent et
dimanche 26 après midi regardez serge
khalfon sais pas si tu peut cadrer là il
ya tous les quarts d'heure alors vous
avez 367.72 points multipliés 7 points
par cinq
ça fait 3 millions et 4 millions et la
grille à vélo
et vous avez 32 on avait fait un carton
jour là ça veut dire que 30 de
téléspectateurs source en 10 manches à
rien de regarder ce moment c'est pas
tout une fois que vous avez ça arrive
la courbe par exemple ça le soit la cour
médias mais notre électrocardiogramme un
autre électroencéphalogramme 11 oui ça
je peux vous dire
à 9h15 quand tombe la comme tu me diras
pas le combat le dimanche matin stones
voilà ça s'est vivement dimanche deux
tiers dont il ya quinze jours cher les
dinos regarder la 4 points d'audience à
venir on commence à deux millions de
spectateurs parce que la pub c'est pas
toujours un avantage pour démarrer mon
menton bon ton monte au monde et vous
arrivez là ça fait douze points minute
par minute
cinq ans ça veut dire que ça ça veut
dire que là certains d'entre vous sont
allés soulager leur vessie et puis sont
venues d'autres un petit peu zappé mais
c'est pas tout votre phrase l après-midi
voyez toute attaque tac tac tac tac
savary 1.2 points c'est assez
vertigineux musqué plus vertigineux
c'est qu'à 11 heures
vous avez les cibles que sa structure
d'audience à préserver les moins de 50
ans les plus de 50 ans les basses à la
fameuse ménager toutes les cibles et ça
c'est extrêmement fiable pourquoi parce
que de cette courbe de cette mesure
statistique des pôles tarifs
publicitaires dont ils n'ont pas intérêt
à se louper et d'ailleurs toutes les
chaînes sont abonnés à médiamétrie et
j'en terminerai et s'en servir et pas
vous dire que si un jour on vient vous
demander chez vous si vous pouvez faire
vous voulez faire partie du panel tu as
eu comment ça fonctionne ça il ya 8500
personnes en france qui pendant
plusieurs années appartiennent au panel
ça représente trois mille sept cents
foyers dans toute la france toute
profession représentation moyenne de la
france petites mains d'entreprises ville
de grand de l'agglomération scheider
tous bords et sur la non non la plupart
s'attendaient pas vous avez chez vous
personne on vous met 1
un petit ordinateur qui correspond à une
télécommande à 6,6 à trois postes chez
vous si vos enfants
regarde un dessin animé sur l'a6 et
qu'ils appuient s'est enregistrée dans
l'ordinateur la nuit qui déposent tous à
levallois perret si vos grands parents
sont dans le salon regard thierry
ardisson ils le savent on dépouille tout
ça est à 9h15 le matin et vous avez ça
et souvent vous passé une mauvaise
journée et je dirais pour conclure et je
dirais bonne chance aux jeunes qui
démarrent et j'ai justement publie
aujourd'hui la la télé c'est des
concepts acheter à l'étranger présenté
par des animateurs interchangeables
c'est la vérité la différence qui entend
le service public qui fête ses 40 ans
lundi et et regarder les mieux
comprendre ce que j en gras dans
l'émission c'est que la différence entre
le service public pour moi et france 2
il s'agit de france 2 et des chaînes
commerciales en général et pas seulement
en france à l'étranger
c'est qu'il ya un attachement du public
très fort pour une chaîne publique où on
retrouve des animateurs qui comme moi
sont là depuis très longtemps
les animateurs services publics sont
pratiquement aussi fort que le concept
qu'il présente moi et les autres sont
des baltringues y en a mais si c'est pas
moi
jack si c'est pas lui qui présente tout
le monde en parle tu regardes pas non si
c'est pas pivot qui aura besoin je
regarde pas si c'est parce oeuvres on
regarde pas et si c'est par là ceux de
la rue qui prend sa discussion notre
émission sevran martin pivot chancel toi
moi on n'est plus des gamins on a tous
plus de cinq ans de la mer noire à
tanger ne revient pas dans les idées ce
n'est pas fini j'te classe dans la
catégorie des meilleurs chroniqueurs de
la télé chroniqueur enfin c'est bien
finir à tout seul
mais dans chroniqueurs dont j'ai
d'ailleurs pas chroniqueur yannick est
alors bien sûr tout ça pour dire que
l'ordinateur du service public pourquoi
se sont aussi forts que le concept qu'il
présente je le noyau ta dépendance à la
cocaïne
tu sais très bien non plus que j'ai
arrêté depuis longtemps et dormait par
mauvais souvenirs le document que je
n'ai pas à porter j'ai un document tu
fumes tard michel à la télé j'ai vu ta
mère à marseille est là elle m'a dit
elle a pas joué alors à la télé il ya
beaucoup d'argent et tu as été toi
soumis à la pression de l'argent à
l'époque quand berlusconi ta ta ta
invités pour aller à ce moment là sur la
cinq as tu es magnifique site a dit vous
possédez quoi monsieur drucker et tu lui
as dit rien oui il est dit que j'ai fait
gagner des montagnes d'argent
les français l'aiment chaud et musique
est ce que vous possédez approche à
l'égard d'un idiot gib.a vous savez bon
j'ai une voiture comme tout le monde
j'ai un appartement que je payer à
crédit à l'époque j'ai une maison à la
campagne petite maison j'espère un jour
d'avoir une plus grande au soleil j'ai
pas de dettes je paye mes impôts et je
suis très content comme ça il me
regardait il me dit et c'est tout ce que
vous possédez un après tant de télé
berlusconi font si big show mais
berlusconi lui il te disais ça vous
tente pas une ferrari
votre femme aime pas le mot not to this
qui m'a dit vers le ce que je vais en
italie le voir il voulait m'engager pour
être conseillé de la chaîne et
l'animateur vitrine ouais il survient
avec un contrat l'incident et le dîner
chez ma mère si je peux pas dire ça
merde c'est à dire qu'on me propose sa
pige arrive mon pauvre frère jean venait
d'être nommé patron de france 2 il est
resté un an et il me dit voilà je suis
un de mes passions de france 2 j'avais
arrêté change d'idée car j'étais crevée
unis faut que tu reprennes j'appelle
berlusconi à milan je lui dit silvio se
tutoyer déjà je peux pas venir chez toi
il me dit c'est pas assez payés jsais
pas le problème c'est des milliards
qu'ils me proposent mais les italiens
d'un sens de la famille mon frère vient
d'être nommé patron de france 2 je vais
l'aider et c'est ce qu'il vit mais
j'achète mon frère aussi
alors michel or on vous reproche souvent
d'être d'être trop gentil
oui vous le savez trop complaisant trop
complaisant alors là j'ai pris une
petite liste de gens sur lesquels je
vais vous demander d'être méchant uribe
dos à guy bedos est un faux mais je peux
pas dire du mal de guy josé réconcilier
tous les guides d'un faux méchant c'est
un type extrêmement entendre on a un
truc méchants très méchants intrigue
méchant
c'est selon il se trompe sur pierre
palmade johnny un truc mais chanson
johnny hallyday a c'est absolument
impossible si johnny un truc très
méchant un truc méchant vraiment méchant
sur un truc il reste du mal la prochaine
fois que j'arrive chez toi comme souvent
le dimanche matin en vélo et qu'ils me
traitent de blaireaux avec mon casque je
te faut un coup de boule ouais un truc
les champs sur bernadette chirac
bernadette chirac pourrait donner des
leçons de générosité à bien des femmes
de gauche comme j'ai dis un truc méchant
michel en méchant je suis pas toujours
d'accord sur ces chapeaux moi j'vais ci
dessous tu m'avais dit un truc méchant
sur belle fille tient au baffie mais
laurence et c'est très compliqué dire du
mal de laurent parce que parce que je
suis il faudrait formidable il faut que
je le connais il faudrait pas que je
connaisse dans la vie et tu le connais
c'est un père de famille très attentif
je suis sûr que c'est un bon père de
famille c'est comme toi il ya des gens
qui me disent vos amis ardisson serre
est une vache chaque soir mais jeudi
mettant des si vous saviez comme c'est
un bon point un bon père de famille et
un bon mari là que je t'ai dit une chose
et ça donne raison
tim est dit un jour c'était quand on
était sur les plages du débarquement
finalement tu as raison il n'y a pas de
honte à être bienveillant tu sais que je
me suis drucké risée mois avec l'âge en
mairie non mais thiery alors
mon problème à moi c'est en 40 ans
gentil mais en 40 ans je me suis fait
tellement de copains même sont pas
vraiment des amis on se connaît trop moi
j'ai reçu jacques souvent johnny je sais
pas combien hassar de également je les
connais trop on finit par avoir et toi
aussi
ça fait combien j'ai fait 7 ans à douala
ouais tu fais la télé depuis combien 20
ans moi je vois bien quand je te regarde
le samedi soir je commence à bien
connaître et lui aussi ayant fini par
être gendarme enfin michel que tu n'as
tu n'as pas d'amis dans ce métier non
j'ai des amis très proches de moi mais
comme j'ai pas eu de vrai coup dur qui
ont remis ma vie en question j'ai pas eu
le temps de les compter le jour j'aurai
vraiment viré de la télévision non mais
je peux avoir cette anxiété tu n'as pas
toi tu vas nous faire ch la can orange
il fallait avec ça bon je veux être là
jeanne calment du paf
oui mais alors tu crois pas si bien dire
est ce que tu sais qu' il y aura dans
les 15 ans qui viennent
9000 centenaires en france tu arriveras
partir là et que dans l'est et que
écouta et que dans les dix ans qui
viennent 10 ans et demain 50% de la
population française aura plus de 50 ans
a en effet déménagé dans wii et dans les
15 ans qui viennent il y aura plus de
gens de 60 ans que de gens de moins de
20 ans messieurs les carrières pour
messieurs les publicitaires à méditer
on est tranquille no koi tp n'a pour 20
ans voilà c'est tout
surtout que tu bois de l'eau tu fume pas
qui fait des abdominaux tu te couches
tôt l'asa sous moi c'est trop lent
[Musique]
merveille dans 40 ans de france de
quarante ans de carrière de michel
drucker
on va faire un petit retour en arrière
on va se retrouver au temps où où tu
cherchais du boulot michel autant de la
rtf
on va faire une interview aux échos
écoute ça peut pas mieux tomber ou ce
que je t'ai à mener pour mes 40 ans de
telle est ma première apparition à la
télé ah ouais j'sais pas si tu cherches
qu'elles font peu cadré de peu car ce
serait bien qu'il y ait ça à l'image
prend aucune position
voilà la tronche que j'avais ma première
apparition alors il est à gauche et
françois jannin reporter françois jannin
oui je m'en souviens et voilà la juge
doit on dirait jean pierre coffe est là
et la cpi à 40 ans dur pour notre photo
vers l'autre photo michel tout de suite
ouais bon serge cals phone call phones
part de faveur à je sais ce que c'est il
ya trente ans je faisais déjà une
émission qui s'appelait rendez vous du
dimanche avec françoise coquet avec rémy
graba qui en avait une scripte charmant
qui s'appelait catherine barba ah oui à
lui a connu script à catherine te voici
voici françoise coquet un assistant
n'ont autant et rien de douloureux et on
voit là montant cayla et à côté de mon
temps à regarder
catherine barma et midi voix qui le dit
catherine barma la fille de claude barma
qui on doit quelques unes des plus
belles pages de la télévision de service
public dont les rois mages les foudres
de la grotte de lascaux michel où il ya
des filles à toi donc ça veut dire gg 20
ans tu as tu as 20 ans oui aujourd'hui
je reçois un jeune qui aimerait bien
faire de la faire de la télé bonjour mon
petit tu t'appelles comment je m'appelle
michel drucker monsieur drucker ça
marchera jamais ça même michel c'est pas
ça marchera jamais non tu veux pas
trouver un nom là j'aurais bien plus
étirés roland roger couderc mais c'était
déjà pris alors tu veux faire la télé
oui pourquoi parce que je sais rien
faire d'autre pour l'instant je n'ai pas
de diplôme il paraît qu'à la télévision
ils n'ont pas dit comme tu sais que ça
gagne pas beaucoup d'argent la télé
michel ouais mais pour l'instant
j'habite place clichy avec ma mère juste
en face chez monsieur citron j'ai pas un
gros besoin
je prends le 80 dacquois comme
expérience
j'ai fait des petits boulots j'ai été
moniteur d'enfants difficiles j'étais
photographe de plage et j'ai été homme
de ménage à orly et je veux surtout pas
retourner affronter le tribunal de la
famille qui nature qui m'a toujours pas
pardonné de ne pas avoir fait d'études
ouais on va voir on étudierait bien dans
quel domaine le sport car je suis un
fondu de ça le divertissement ça te
dirait oui mais albert raisner ya guy
lux im et mortimer
ouais il ya des gens déjà très costaud
jean nohain donc ben bourgeois en ce
moment oui mais raisonnable oui
tu aimerais présenter des variétés un
jour michel bassi un jour on me le
demande je sais qu'il ya une dame qui
m'a qui que j'aimerais rencontrer qu'
une grande productrice à la débloquer
michel arnaud michard nommé je la
connais très bien je peux te présenter
c'est la productrice de gens qui sont
avertis elle était en plus elle a le
bras long puisqu'elle a été la maîtresse
de françois mitterrand bah oui elle a eu
comme pianiste serge gainsbourg
j'aimerais bien la rencontre et bomba
coûte ça ça peut s'arranger thème les
vedettes mon petit michel
j'aime les vedettes du sport j'aime
jacques anquetil j'aime fausto coppi et
j'aime par dessus tout raymond kopa est
juste fontaine est ce que tu sais que
les vedettes faut être gentil avec elle
pour qu'elle revienne régulièrement dans
des émissions tu as bien compris ça
on m'a appris à être gentil à la maison
et à remercier beaucoup je deviens ce
côté provoc un peu destroy de mon jeune
frère car fait l'ena dis moi tu as des
défauts taqwa comme défaut michel je
sais pas dire non
ouais je suis prêt à dépanner de mille
balles je suis très impatient j'ai du
mal à me concentrer c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas fait d'études et puis j'ai un
gros défaut c'est que c'est que je je
demande à tous les jours à ma famille
qu'est ce que je ferai demain
oui je suis obsédée par peur fait pas
michel t'en fais pas arte trouver
quelque chose pour toi je voudrais
absolument réussir quelque part ça me
calme toi tu as l'air très inquiet toi
juste très inquiet ah oui je suis très
inquiet d'ailleurs j'ai dû encaisser ce
que vous ne savez pas quels mets
vraiment bien vous dites la vérité
puisque j'ai 20 ans et déjà un début
d'ulcère à d'estomac j'ai fait un zona
ya trois mois ah ouais nan mais faut que
ça s'arrête
est-ce que tu fumes monty michel non tu
fume pas non plus de drogues non
j'aimerais bien me droguais non j'aime
pas le drogué monsieur c'est quoi ça oui
à prendre la température
sylvain vous c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
je n'essayais imagine le gars qui zappe
qui tombe ce qu'ils me voient comme ça
maintenant on est obligé de fermer le
test pour les gens qui venaient aussi ça
s'est produit trop c'est un petit
contrôle jacques oui ça doit venir
commencent ils à vue avec jacques même
s'il n'a pas vu ça va changer de couleur
alors laurent c'est tout à fait normal
là je regarde le résultat il n'ya pas
bourré bourré très bourg et toi ces
greffes de foie
c'est très bien là du match 85 ans parle
en fait de la télévision et non mais
j'espère justement rester plus de 50
ares i je peux rentrer à des visions je
voudrais rester très longtemps et une
voix ou dans 40 ans à la télévision
ah ouais tu crois vraiment que tu prends
encore de la télé mon image et là rien
je serai bien puisque 1 mais zidane à la
télévision léon zitrone chapatte couderc
et les autres ils ont 50 ans on n'a
jamais avoir 50 ans à la tête à une tête
de gendre idéal en cas déjà dit non j'ai
une tête de cendres idéal ouais je sais
pas c'est vrai si si si tu crois si si
moi je trouve que ça peut simplement
avec les filles ça marche moyen mais il
paraît que à la télévision quand on se
fait connaître ça marche mieux là et tu
vas voir ta piège affirmant qu' à demain
dans ton émission mon petit michel
ségolène royal la présidente de région
poitou charentes de les secousses et les
accompagne la compagne de françois
hollande et avec véronique sanson il en
perd est bien mal ni un petit scoop
c'est je ne savais pas qu'elle avait
pratiqué le piano donc elle est au
complet
non mais quand tu joues c'est à dire est
la compagne véronique sens mais tout le
monde le sait à bombay manque pas de
charme ouais elle est pas mal de la
pêche michel elle est nulle son mari non
et bien son mari quand on le connaît pas
alors on n'imagine pas que c'est un type
extrêmement drôle quand on le connaît en
france ont résisté
voilà
sur france 2
bon
lucas
bonsoir exemple et sébastien qui est un
copain à moi ou ça sébastien sébastien
présente toi
bonsoir le public je me présente je sui
sébastien prulhière et je mène des défis
par rapport à ma maladie neuromusculaire
et par rapport aussi un autre handicap
qu'ils soient plus beaucoup c'est le
bégaiement et de là est née une passion
d'intériorité personnalité c'est le défi
c'est view seb lance un défi est donc
j'ai déjà interviewé par même de
personnalités dont un clint eastwood un
jeu posé de questions au festival de
cannes
et avec ces personnalités je lance un
défi à réaliser dans l'année 1 avant mon
opération ou après mon opération qui
peut avoir un but de sébastien s'est
fait opérer régulièrement pour pour
rester debout pour marcher donc c'est
vraiment une bataille incroyable effet
des défis en plus il a tu va traverser
la seine en canoë kayak le 4 novembre
le 4 novembre avec un chant donc il faut
lui filer un coup de main voilà avec un
champion olympique inquiets benoît péché
et je vais traverser une partie à
contre-courant une partie sur la
descente en une traversée de 10 km
[ __ ] donc il faut être là qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire ça va devenir le 4
novembre
il faut venir le 4 novembre mais elles
allaitent on cite mais par contre je
commence à 7h du matin et on va se lever
en sauver saab parle de ton site a
séduit cimt oncle mon site internet ces
médias handicap point orgue regarde ça
passe c'est la magie du direct mais
tient son handicap était qu un trucage
autres étant le but de l'association
c'est de réunir l'ensemble des médias
pour permettre une personne handicapée
de jouer un rôle dans la vie médiatique
en tant que d'interviewer merci merci
merci scène
il
[Musique]
sarah michel ça va bien une chose avec
des croquis ou par non non mais je
m'adresse à ceux qui vont nous suivre
encore là ma carrière la carrière elle
est faite et tout ce qui se passe
maintenant c'est que 48 ans maintenant
c'est une grande gueule charles naveau à
81 ans donc je le dire simplement à nos
jeunes animateurs qui veulent essayer de
s'inscrire dans la durée
je vous réponds d'une formule excellente
qui est de marc tessier ou comme sa
conférence de presse où il a dit la tv
au service public doit être insolente
imprévisible
c'est le cas ici mais jamais à descente
et qu'il ne faut jamais confondre la
télévision de proximité avec la
télévison de promiscuité
waouh et je trouvais je peux faire
m
[Musique]
merci michel merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup merci thierry à bientôt
je peux être une dernière question quant
à 1 minute quand est ce que tu écris tes
mémoires
bah écoute normalement ça va sortir en
2005 ah voilà des toits qui va balancer
dans tes mémoires de la jungle mettre
les noms là non je vais pas crier
mémoire tout de suite parce que comme
dirait thierry j'ai peur que ça sent le
sapin
[Rires]
ça va
ballottés rien
ouais
maintenant caroline fourest
[Musique]
et
bonsoir caroline fourest vous êtes
journaliste d'investigation spécialiste
des intégrismes rédactrice en chef du
journal pro choix et vous publié chez
grasset un livre dans tout le monde
parle qui s'appelle frère tariq voilà
alors frère tariq consacré à tariq
ramadan tariq ramadan est souvent
présenté dans les médias comme un
intellectuel musulman qui veut
moderniser l'islam
beaucoup de gens lui ont reproché en
fait de tenir un double langage d'être
un fondamentaliste déguisez vous vous
avez voulu en avoir le coeur net
vous avez étudié vous avez étudié ses
livres ses cassettes ses interviews et
donc on va vérifier en passant point par
point ce qu'il raconte est ce que vous
vous avez trouvé au terme de votre
enquête voilà vous êtes prête je suis
prête bien
alors on va commencer avec sa filiation
tariq ramadan est le petit fils du
fondateur des frères musulmans qui est
une confrérie islamiste
alors lui il dit je n'y appartiens pas à
cette confrérie des frères musulmans et
en fait quand on me soupçonne dit
appartenir
c'est dit-il un délit génétique un petit
peu comme ya un délit de faciès
en fait vous vous dites que il
appartient à cette confrérie mais comme
elle est secrète il peut pas dire qui
lui appartient ni appartenir à la
confrérie des frères musulmans comme à
peu près 90% des frères musulmans
il faut bien comprendre que c'est pas
une organisation dont on a ça car tout
comme un martyr en fait être à mme
dumont c'est une école de pensée et ont
défini un frère musulman par le fait
qu'ils adhèrent à la pensée et à la
méthode de hassan al-banna et c'est là
où le tariq ramadan se moque un peu de
nous parce que on lui reproche pas
d'être le petit fils de bana on lui
reproche d'enseignés aujourd'hui d'être
la personne qui fait le plus pour
diffuser la pensée la méthode de son
grand-père qu'il présente dans ces
cassettes comme le modèle à suivre
le plus grand réformiste de ce siècle un
type formidable qui avait une méthode
extraordinaire et une pensée l'un pied
des élus site qu'il faut suivre
aujourd'hui
donc vous dites qu'en fait ils
prolongent l'enseignement de son grand
père et de son père saïd ramadan et
surtout une vision très importante c'est
qu'il a compris que tout se jouer en
europe
qu'il fallait venir au coeur de l'europe
pour islamiser le vieux continent et
c'est comme ça qu'il a démarré en 61
centres islamiques à genève avec il faut
bien le dire l'argent des saoudiens qui
y voyaient un moyen de répandre la foi
fondamentalistes et aussi avec une
certaine bénédiction des américains
qu'ils aient trouvé que c'était un moyen
formidable de lutter contre le
communisme alors sur les frères
musulmans vous dit contrairement à ce
que raconte tariq ramadan il est bien un
frère musulman il est bien un frère
musulman les l'homme aujourd'hui qui
fait le plus en europe et dans tout le
monde francophone pour diffuser la place
en dentaire le deuxième point le respect
des lois de la république
en fait la vraie question c'est de
savoir si on place l'islam au dessus des
lois de la république ou si les lois de
la république
préval sur l'islam dans plusieurs de ses
livres vous pouvez lire qu'il appelle
les musulmans à respecter le cadre du
pays où ils vivent et quand vous allez
écouter sa cassette vous comprenez qu'en
réalité ce qu'ils me disent c'est
respecte le cadre à condition qu'aucune
loi ne s'oppose en principe islamique
ce qui fait une petite différence ouais
alors sur le voile lui il arrête pas de
dire tariq ramadan qu'il faut pas
obliger les jeunes musulmanes à porter
le voile
vous vous dites oui effectivement il dit
ça quand il est en public quand il à la
télévision mais n'en faites dans ces
cassettes il dit qu'une bonne musulmane
est une musulmane pudique et il parle de
féminisme islamique
donc c'est mieux d'avoir un voile ah oui
c'est mieux d'avoir un voile puisque ans
en fait ce qu'il dit c'est que
on l'a déjà fait mademoiselle il a déjà
été invité ici et ça m'a été assez et ça
m'a été assez reproché d'avoir invité
tariq ramadan puisque on a été les
premiers à l'invité avant 100 minutes
pour convaincre
avant serge moati dans riposte et sam a
été assez reproché donc tous là dessus
ici on reçoit vous savez bien qu'ici
c'est une émission libre il est tout le
temps dans les médias on voit que lui
il est tout le temps sur les plateaux
télévision il parle tout le temps à la
place des musulmans libéraux et laïque
alors qu'il l'est qu'il est vomi à
longueur de cassettes ce qui est quand
même un peu gros et je peux faire une
pression par rapport à ça c'est que ça
fait plus de quatre semaines une
émission sur service public a proposé
tariq ramadan à face à face avec moi il
a toujours refusé d'accepter
donc j'attends toujours servette chabot
vous dites que le voile en fait il ya
deux discours un discours officiel si
vous ne voulez pas porter le voile c'est
pas grave mais en fait il d'être une
bonne musulmane avec la la pudeur de la
bonne musulmane et le féminisme
islamique il faut porter un voile n'est
pas idiot tu es un écrivain dont il sait
bien que s'il va devant des jeunes
maghrébines ou des jeunes d'origine
maghrébine leur dire allez il faut
mettre le voile c'est comme ça c'est
obligatoire c'est dans le coran il
secondera un retour de weis sur les
mariages mixtes tariq ramadan lui il est
d'accord pour que des musulmans et
pousse des non musulmans c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il a fait lui en
épousant une femme qui s'appelle
isabelle qui est catholique
isabelle la catholique est en revanche
dans l'autre sens ça marche pas c'est à
dire qu'une femme musulmane n'a pas le
droit d'épouser un non musulman ce qui
est conforme au coran est un écrin blanc
autant que fondamentalistes suis sur ce
point le coran lui les obsédés par une
chose c'est la da'wa c'est à dire la
prédication et faire grandir le nombre
de croyants en europe donc il est par
définition hostile au mariage mixte qui
font diminuer le nombre de croyants pour
lui c'est une perte pour la oumma pour
la l'ensemble des musulmans la oumma oui
donc il dit qu'en fait il faut éviter
les mariages mixtes
il faut les éviter en amont parce que en
fait ça se termine toujours mal en vo
c'est cette selma leurs assurés ouais
alors sur la polygamie il est contre ou
pour justifier la polygamie dans son
dernier livre qui s'appelle peut-on
vivre l'islam
à condition que les premières épouses
soient d'accord à condition d'un
traitement équitable entre les épouses
qui là aussi est effectivement une
lecture fondamentaliste du coran mais
mes fidèles et aux fondements du corps
c'est à la polygamie c'est des choses
qui le dit uniquement dans ses écrits en
arabe destiné à la communauté musulmane
où est ce qu'ils ont su resserrer cette
en arabe parce que c'est vrai qu'on l'a
beaucoup dit moi j'ai vraiment ramasser
ce qu'on trouvait dans les libres et
islamistes à portée de tous les
cassettes sont en français il ya une
incantation religieuse en arabe au début
et il s'exprime la plupart du temps en
france fait donc ses cassettes sont en
français les choses les plus graves
qu'il dit ce sont en france est d'accord
alors sur le fait de pouvoir battre sa
femme quelle est sa position avec comme
d'habitude il se ils se déchargent sur
des savants qui sont encore plus
fondamentale disque lui c'est à dire
qu'il dit il prédit rien sur la question
parce qu'il n'est pas théologien il faut
bien être clair sur un point tariq
ramadan s'est ni animal ni un théologien
c'est un prédicateur bien vous dise il
va pas fait le l'université d'al azhar
au caire dont il est pathologique à une
formation extrêmement réduite sur ces
questions là en réalité le seul islam
qu'ils connaissent et l'islam politique
des frères musulmans
en dehors de quoi il est assez perdu
donc quand on lui pose une question
comme sur ce point là il conseille un
théologien qui est le théologien des
frères musulmans qu'ils aillent au cf al
qardaoui et youssef al qardaoui qui a
écrit le licite et l'illicite en islam
est connu pour autoriser à battre sa
femme si elle est indiscipliné mais ne
jamais en venir à la considérer comme
une esclave
non tu laisses ta paix mais il faut pas
la considérer comme une esclave alors la
lapidation donc là c'était à la
télévision c'était sur france 2 pendant
100 minutes pour convaincre
nicolas sarkozy a demandé à tariq
ramadan ans était favorable de
lapidation des femmes adultères et il a
dit il faudrait qu'il ya un moratoire
c'est quoi un moratoire un moratoire
chez tariq ramadan c'est mettons des
savants tous islamistes parce que pour
lui les noms islamistes ne sont pas
musulmans autour de la table et parlons
ensemble pour voir si on peut mettre fin
à l'application de sa peine sauf qu il
précise que sa position est minoritaire
parmi ces savants c'est à dire qu'il
propose un moratoire entre savants
majoritairement pro lapidation et qui
veut voir ce que ça donne
alors c'est très simple parce qu on y re
ans a déjà eu lieu on a mis des savants
majoritairement pro lapidation autour de
la table ils sont tombés d'accord pour
maintenir la lapidation
ça devrait pas tellement choqué tariq
ramadan puisqu'elle a déclaré là aussi
dans un livre très récent que la
fornication et l'adultère sont des
choses très graves devant du injustement
on y arrive
l'homosexualité est interdite mais saab
on parle coran par la religion
catholique par par la religion juive je
dire c'est là un extraordinaire ça non
mais ya que les croyants extrêmement
fondamentaliste et intégriste pour
considérer que c'est toujours valable
tariq ramadan considèrent que
l'homosexualité est un déséquilibre et
qu'il faut lutter de toutes ses forces
pour conseiller ses pauvres déséquilibré
à retourner vers une procréation plus
naturel ce qui moi me me frappe dans
cette histoire c'est que quand un
intégriste chrétien comme botellon
récemment parlement européen tient de
tels propos
ouais tourne à juste titre ou un sacré
bordel n'arrive pas à comprendre comment
tariq ramadan lui continue d'être à la
fois invité dans les médias comme un
musulman libéral présent au forum social
européen
alors qu'il tient des propos que
christine boutin renierait pas quoi
ouais alors sur la sodomie bon il est
contre là c'est pareil que toutes les
autres religions je dirais mais même la
sodomie hétérosexuels et des conseillers
ils appellent ça la petite homosexualité
ne visite pas ta femme par l'anus mais
là aussi c'est une nature fondamentale
du commun alors sur la condamnation du
11 septembre
vous dites qu'en fait il tient pas le
même discours là aussi entre ce qui est
dit dans les médias dans les journaux à
la télé à la radio et ce qu'il dit quand
il avec d'autres d'autres musulmans il
dit par exemple dites vous la
culpabilité de ben laden n'est pas
prouvée il a un don pour l'euphémisme
tareq ramadan quand il parle des
attentats du 11 septembre et de madrid
il parle d'intervention quand il parle
de l'assassinât de sadate en egypte ya
quelques années il parle d'exécution et
tout est comme ça celle qui vit dans un
monde où les musulmans libéraux sont des
musulmans je le cite sans l'islam et où
par contre les intégristes sont les bons
musulmans
alors effectivement il sait se faire
passer pour un juste milieu c'est-à-dire
qu'ils expliquent souvent quand on
attaque
oui mais il ya des djihadistes qui me
traitent de modérer s'il ya en gros il
ya des types qui veulent faire sauter la
planète qui me trouvent modéré ça veut
pas dire que c'est un musulman libéral
il dit aussi israël avait intérêt au
massacre
il a une façon très claire de pointé du
doigt tout ce qui est juif
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème dans le
monde il faut se tourner chaque fois que
lui même est victime par exemple de
critiques à son endroit il a une façon
assez systématique de désigner whey
lobby juif comme responsable il est
dangereux pour vous tariq ramadan il est
d'autant plus dangereux que justement on
ne sait pas qu'il est vraiment qu'on ne
prend pas le temps de lire ses discours
c'est pour ça que j'ai eu envie de le
faire et surtout ce que lui reprochent
depuis des années les intellectuels
musulmans laïques
c'est qu'il passe à qui parle à leur
place alors qu'ils mènent un combat au
nom de l'islam fondamentaliste comme
entre toute modernisation d'islam alors
tariq ramadan va bientôt publier un
livre écrit avec aziz zemouri qui
s'appelle faut-il faire taire tariq
ramadan est ce que vous vous pensez
qu'il faut faire taire tariq ramadan moi
je suis pour la liberté d'expression à
partir du moment où on est informé
si j'ai fait ce livre c'est pas pour
faire taire tariq ramadan c'est pour que
les gens aient un point de comparaison
est un moyen de se rendre compte ce qui
se cache derrière le discours officiel
je demande pas être cru sur parole
chaque fois je le cite je renvoie à une
note à ses yeux très documenté oui c'est
vrai
moi je suis parti d'un principe très
simple tariq ramadan dit depuis des
années chaque fois qu'on m'attaque matt
action grand-père m'attaque sur mon
frère on m'attaque pas sur mes discours
gelé simplement pris au mot j'ai
travaillé pendant dix mois pour
justement faire connaître ce discours au
grand public
et j'espère que les gens jugeront à
partir de ça pour se faire une idée
précise parce que je crois qu'on vit
dans une époque on peut plus se
contenter malheureusement des apparences
notamment sur la question d'un
intégrisme moi j'ai travaillé dix ans
sur les intégristes chrétiens ils ont
ils ont une grande qualité les
intégristes chrétiens c'est qu'ils sont
tellement caricaturaux que généralement
on les voit venir des séries j'ai
notamment travaillé chez christine
boutin c'est vrai que c'était un peu un
béni à côté de tariq ramadan c'était un
bonheur je regrette cette époque et cet
âge d'or je ne vous le cache pas tariq
ramadan c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est beaucoup plus difficile et c'est
pour ça que ça demande un travail
d'explication et un livre merci
[Applaudissements]
à qui
allez
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
émotionnel
michel voulait que je l'accompagnais à
sa voiture il voulait me montrer des
pictogrammes des courbes des biens tu
sais qui en accueille maintenant oui
tariq ramadan
non garou
garou te laisser laurent baffie bonsoir
bon voilà c'est ma première question
vous qui savait tout faire chanter
danser jouer la comédie
pourquoi vous arrêtez pas cet accent
recommence avec sa série là parce que
quand même il faut dire que tirée à 10
ans et donnait même chez nous parce que
maintenant tout le monde en parle ça
existe ça marche bien
quand on dit avec la commission ça veut
dire c'est comme un gros mot
dix ans non mais ça marche bien tout le
monde en parle au québec ah non mais
c'est pas comme ça qu'on dit thierry et
sait comment moins bon la barre à bas
prix tout le monde en parle avec guy a
lepage
oui ça fait 6 1% de part de marché la
balle tu m'aimais 108000 1 4000 ménages
vous savez qu'ils étaient ainsi la
semaine dernière votre place non joe
cocker pas à la lazio comme quoi d'une
semaine sur l'autre il est super beau
mais il ya il ya dix ans avant plamandon
avant quasimodo dans notre dame de paris
vous chantiez du joe cocker dans les
dimanches à garou dans un lit car store
phone est un showman berlin
tu sais quoi jeudi je pense que tu es le
successeur de géniale idée moi c'est
pour but de remplacer qui que ce soit
les c'est un échec si je remplace
quelqu'un ce n'est chercheurs ouais mais
j'espère avoir mon identité donc je vais
garder mon accent québécois garou c'est
ça
c'est un bon coureur
e
[Musique]
dans ce cas
noise ou pied danser
on sort du
alors le champ
faire sourire sommet
celui
oui
[Musique]
lycée
da
gao war alors le premier album le
premier album s'appelait seuls 3 2
millions d'exemplaires
le deuxième album revient et les sorties
un an avec ça
[Musique]
bonjour
vraiment inconnu de génial il y était
d'accord lors non plus ce joe cocker je
trouve moi
moi je n'entendrais plus chaud en 10
mois j'ai eu orlando tu connais
relandeau à l'orlando est oui orlando
donc j'ai eu à orlando
alors je lui dis qu'il est pas de clip
j'ai dit c'est seulement un extrait du
concert
et là il s'est roulé par terre et la
finale à il exactement exactement ça si
j'ai un clip orlando que je connais oui
orlando et orlando a dit que même s'ils
n'étaient pas un clip il fallait quand
même que tu dises magnéto serge en
regardant la caméra donc tu es un petit
peu obligé de le faire un garrot où je
regarde une caméra guy hoquet magnéto
serge
deux vélos conçus sur les nerfs du super
six le 20 août
m
un peu
[Musique]
m
toi
l'homme
/
[Musique]
voilà alors ça c'est extrait donc du
deuxième album qui s'appelle reviens le
prochain single garou c'est le duo avec
michel sardou la rivière de notre
enfance il sympa sans doute oui le
nouveau particulier qui est vraiment
sympathique
pour la peine de mort tout ça mais pour
moi c'est la plus belle voix masculines
de la francophonie ça ouais ouais non
c'est toi la plus belle voix de la
francophone locale aloses
dans ma zone
[Musique]
alors j'ai vu orlando lamoureux toi je
suis pas amoureux j'aurais jamais que de
l'eau et orlando il a il a dit pareil
que tu regarde ta caméra et tout en
disant magnéto serge magnéto serge non
[Musique]
police vous êtes cernés a sur la tête
voilà la rivière notre enfance bien
renouer michel sardou cdd merci merci
beaucoup c'est une idée michel sardou
quand même de de couper le pied pas la
fin et de faire ça encore chanter trop
fort c'est pas mal donc ça pour vrai ça
fait mal ça prouve que ce dernier pour
la déconne alors gare où vous êtes en
tournée depuis des mois c'est incroyable
vous êtes un petit peu fatigué vous avez
eu un petit surmenage au mois de
septembre après avoir fait cinq mille
spectateurs à moscou 9000 à saint
pétersbourg tournée mondiale
pratiquement et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé alors j'ai eu très peur parce que
je suis un excessif dans plein de choses
donc j'aime vivant dans plein de choses
garou comme on a compris la liste mais
c'est vrai qu'on est un spectacle et
j'ai eu ce qu'on appelle un coup de
fouet à un accident de cordes vocales et
au moment où le dr a dit tu arrêtes toi
non sinon tu écopes
un an sans chanter tu pourras plus
jamais bon dès lors je n'ai justement
laurent très bons enchaînements bravo
laurent parce qu'on en a un on a
soupçonné garuda clamant d'isabelle
adjani
c'est ridicule quel enchaînement mais
c'est aussi nos essais cassé avec pascal
obispo voilà un
voilà pour bien récupérer fait pas
question de s'afficher avec avec gao
mais j'ai regretté quand même si deux ou
trois jours où on est et où on sait
jamais parlé ni rencontré à ce que je l'
ai quand même quand même jamais
rencontré donc ça va être assez mignon
qu'en france moment la première fois
comment les gens peuvent inventer des
trucs pareils
je sais pas celle là je vais pas compris
que d'habitude on voit toujours des
trucs on met en avant une meilleure
sélection après le test salivaire
voilà même nom c'est une copine avec qui
je peux très bien aller au restaurant et
d'amis stephanie monaco il ya eu un
moment non c'est vrai on m'avait appelé
on m'avait de vue te fait la nation en
quoi ma gueule
black machine et au téléphone c'était le
match no 3 et pourquoi est on me
racontait une histoire en effet avec
avec stéphanie de monaco parce que on
s'est rencontrés on en a on n'était pas
de tout de suite et sa petite fille est
une fan et on a fait des photos ensemble
et il a glissé les gens te si c'est à
cause de quoi c'est à cause de votre
voix kaki et super craquant si ça vous
imagine garou avec une boîte de fausser
la fef étude de prendre une voix aiguë
pouvoir tu peux chanter comme toi non
non ça n'arrive pas on va faire avec une
autre voie
[Musique]
alors donc vous devez me répondre avec
une petite voix gao d'accord ça va garou
soit vous appelez gare est maintenant ça
fait plus laetitia casta
elle vous plaît votre nouvelle voie ça
va ça va je pourrais m'habituer ça vous
fait quoi garuda voir le corps d'un
homme et d'avoir patrick juvet je
n'aurais découvre comment vous allez
expliquer ça à vos parents cette
nouvelle voie ça va être plus facile que
d'expliquer cela ventre vous allez
continuer à chanter avec cette nouvelle
voie garot si je vais essayer mais je
vais essayer surtout de d'aller un peu
en boîte pour la restructurer vous avez
chanté quel genre de chanson maintenant
maintenant je vais faire je vais faire
un peu de télé réalité je crois oui vous
pouvez me chanter une de vos chansons
pour voir la belle avec cette voie
comment ça fait beh c'est un mot qu'on
dirait un boulot de ce que ça vous tente
un boulot de secrétaire
oui c'est pas moi je vais vous apprendre
comment pour draguer maintenant avec
cette nouvelle voie dite moi par exemple
que vous me trouvais jolie gao dans
votre cave peut-être que ça va
fonctionner vous avez dit prendre comme
ça maintenant pour driver j'ai très bien
autre chose parce qu'en fait c'est vrai
que sans ma voix tant disait jean-pierre
fait un de nos poètes québécois
je suis devenu boulet jour où j'ai eu
une guitare dans les mains il ya des
salariés vous donneriez quoi garou pour
retrouver votre ancien voix je donnerai
tout parce que c'est le truc que je ne
veux pas perdre entre ça je ne sais pas
encore
gao
je me
[Musique]
verissimo
soir et connaissent et garonne oui non
non on parle avec la nouvelle voie
garrot il a perdu sa voix
voilà alors vous êtes ici pour banlieue
13 un film de pierre morel scénario de
luc besson et bibi nacéri fait mal pitch
pouvoir on est en 2011 2011 et 2013 2013
2013 est en fait en 2011 on a on a mis
un mur d'isolement tout autour de la
banlieue puisque l'état ne savons plus
quoi faire de la recrudescence de la
violence a décidé d'isoler toute la
racaille
voilà comme new york 1997 un peu un peu
oui c'est un peu john carpenter ballard
et voilà c'est une banlieue où règnent
les gangs
les dealers c'est le ghetto en fait le
gouvernement nous a totalement abandonné
dans cette dans cette banlieue et comme
ils savent plus quoi faire face à toute
cette racaille pense juste à mettre une
bombe étrangères péter voilà il ya une
arme de destruction massive a fait un
bond propre qui doit péter voilà on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble dany vous
avez regardé votre caméra en dix ans
magnéto serge sellier un rouge magnéto
serge harry 2013 dont les cités ghettos
entourée d'un mur d'isolement
les gangs règne en maître absolu quel
est le but de prendre mission quand on
sait qu'on n'a aucune chance de la
réussir à vous les jeux désamorcer une
bombe venue de la pire des banlieues
dans laquelle j'ai jamais mis les pieds
avouez que c'est pas très actif à 23
heures pour monter cette merde ce qui
concerne les lieux on vous a trouvé un
guide les taux transfert
parce qu'en plus faut travailler en
tandem tu rentreras cité
on en tue sortons manuel de police
encore garda la page suis dans la merde
merde à la retrouver c'est bon tu
t'occupes que ta gueule quand les
bourgeois que tu critiques
qu'est ce que tu veux plus te préviens
si tu me touches je plains m'occuper
d'elle il atteint seraient damas bon ben
ça fait de raison de rester présent
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce truc là j'ai pas un cadeau
c'est un cadeau lis mon frère
un truc est urgent ton histoire ça sent
l'embrouillé
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à faire chier
hollande
c'est ma bagnole qui est en train de
défoncer la j'ai piqué fourgon de merck
avait plus de fraîcheur une réfugiée
autant mal aiguillé mon gars ici c'est
pas monaco c'est bagdad
voilà banlieue 13 sorti le 10 novembre
alors vous jouez de la caissière de
supermarché qui est capturé par le chef
du gang pour servir de monnaie des
changes
ma pauvre dany le chef du gang donc vous
vous vous drogue et vous enchaîne un
missile d'où le nom gang bang il ya un
moment terrible dans le film parce que
vous traversez une salle avec des mecs
torse nu et les mecs vous dise ne soit
pas perso laisse néanmoins ta culotte
vous leur dites je vous ferais bouffer
votre culotte et à la fin nous fait
bouffer votre culotte au mac quand même
j'ai pris énormément de plaisir
ah ouais j'ai vraiment kiffé non je dis
ça parce que bertrand delanoë dit
toujours qu'on parle pas de petite
culotte dans cette émission je voulais
dire quand même qu'on en parle bien sûr
très régulièrement et avait clairement
c'est flagrant
alors le film banlieue 13 vous n'êtes
pas très dépaysé parce que finalement
c'est la banlieue vous était de 9,4 à
vitry élevé par votre mère vous dit
j'étais un boulet pour elle votre mère a
travaillé dans un l'isabelle ses riads
de police elle rentrait tard le soir
fatigué et vous vous attendiez chez chez
une voisine
au début il trouvait pas de nourrice
pour garder et la seule bonne idée
qu'elle a trouvé c'était de fermer la
porte à clé c'était une porte blindée
donc à ce moment là les voisins lui ont
dit mais attention un jour il ya le feu
de gaz qu'est ce que tu fais puis là ce
moment là même envoyé chez une nourrice
qui était sourde et muette
aïe aïe aïe c'est pour ça qu'elle
prenait 5 go elle les attendait pas donc
vous n'avez qu'une idée si vous cassez
de la coi absolument
ouais vous le faites quand vous avez 17
ans vous partez votre mère vous vire un
peu en même temps ouais elle a eu un
bonhomme qui était pas très sympa avec
moi au début et puis bon bah maintenant
que j'habite plus à la maison
il est adorable avec moi mais on va dire
j'ai pas fait le deuil de ça et je suis
pas vraiment pardonné
ouais à ce moment là vous faites des
petits boulots vous bossez au quid des
halles ou pas c'est quand même autre bac
français
mais vous réalisez que vous avez pas
assez de fric pour vous acheter des
livres pour faire terminale même si je
mens jamais à gibert jeune les acheter
c'est pas avec ma paye du coup et que je
pouvais tout n est pas vous êtes acama
kivu tabac sans plus ouais
malheureusement je suis tombé sur un
manipulateur de première vous posez 40
kg ouais ouais ouais parce qu'en fait il
m'a fait un sacré lavage de cerveau
l'enfoiré et en fait quand on tombe sur
un mec comme ça il vous prend ici vous
isole dont ce n'était pas très difficile
puisque je voyais plus ma famille mais
en même temps j'étais n'était pas assez
forte pour réaliser toute l'emprise
qu'il avait sur moi donc ça passait par
des fois où il venait me surveiller
carrément à mon boulot pour voir ce que
je faisais si j'avais le malheur de
prendre une méreau d'un téléphone d'un
mec parce qu'en même temps au forum des
halles il ya énormément de passage et on
se fait beaucoup
draguer quand on est caissière au quick
parce qu'ils essaient toujours d'avoir
des
et qui se veut regard en plus des script
comme ça et forcément on prend un numéro
de téléphone bon après on jette à la
poubelle
mon prend pour pas faire de scandale
quoi parce qu'un vigile face à une bande
de quinze mecs c'est pas possible
alors c'est l'époque donc on vous
surnomme ally mcbeal parce que vous vous
ressemblez un petit peu au moins par le
poids et la taille à l'héroïne de
manière voilà l héroïne du feuilleton
et puis bon ben voilà vous avez un
boulot ou fait chier un mec qui vous
tape sur la gueule et vous vous rêvez
d'une autre vie vous rêvez de cinéma ce
moment là et vous commencez à faire des
castings mais on vous dit bakhit et toi
comment tu veux y arriver t pearson
kuaté personne tu es la fille de
personne n'a aucun piston t'as pas fait
les cours florent t'as pas fait un tel
qu aucune chance quoi voilà et même en
leur demandant de me faire passer un
essai quoi de me d'essayer mais bon moi
je suis croyant dur comme fer je croyais
en ma bonne étoile et n'ont jamais
laissé il ya quelqu'un qui vous dit elle
seule chance c'est de coucher pour
réussir
alors celui là michel drucker qui est
pas m'arrêter là tout à l'heure avec ses
petits pictogrammes
[Rires]
d'accord quand le mec vous dit ça ça
nous fait complètement craquer vous vous
chialez épices et là vous voyez une
petite annonce pour dépend des photos de
charme
oui oui parce que je me suis dis bah
tiens peut-être que je pèse même si je
pèse 40 kg j'avais envie de me sentir
belle dans les yeux d'un homme qu'un
homme désire et problème c'est quand on
a une bouille de bébé
même si on est branché mecque de la
trentaine quarantaine et là la pression
de draguer sa fille quoi l'antenne ça
marche pas des masses
ouais vous appelez donc pour les photos
de charme et vous tombez sur john
beyrouth que je ne connais pas personne
ne me regarde pas que des yeux de cocker
je ne connais pas cet individu tu
pouvais bien l'étude de john beyrouth
quand même nom à bord non je regardais
quoi avec ta femme le soir
bah on écoute mozart surtout et après on
baise et là vous commencez à faire des
films porno sous le nom de ali mac tiana
ali à cause d'ally mcbeal et tiana parce
que c'est votre deuxième prénom oui tout
à fait donc là vous commencez les films
porno ça a été dur les films pornos noms
nagy avait quand même une place
privilégiée 1 je dois choisir avec qui
ou dans quel contexte
j'étais un peu la chouchoute ainsi je
voulais pas je voulais pas si on allait
tout va bien je faisais ma loin ouais
sauf que là le votre mec vous retrouvez
vous m'aidez pas ouais il m'a retrouvé
basse comme ça dans la rue et une
pareillement tubes et on en vient on va
boire un verre je voudrais m'excuser
tout ça et là
quand on arrive chez les pour boire un
verre à ce moment là bas il prend un
journal et je me prends un gros coup
dans la figure et à ce moment là j'étais
au téléphone avec ma meilleure amie elle
entend que je me fait fracasser elle
complètement paniquée elle prévient john
qui lui pouvait rien faire quand ils
savaient pas où ils étaient entre mamans
sortir il est toujours en vie ce gala
ouais voulait pas pensé non je pense que
je je je je prie pour lui pour que s'il
serait un cas dans la prochaine ville
qui se réincarne que la douleur soit pas
trop dur alors ensuite vous vous
réfugiez à l'armée du salut au palais de
la femme c'est quoi le palais de la
femme alors le palais de la femme c'est
c'est une grande bâtisse qui ressemble
un peu à vachement une forteresse
puisqu'il ya des grillages le soir où il
ya 1500 femmes qui dorment c ou c 20e
c'est rue de charonne dans le 11e ouais
ils ont déplacé des caisses qui s'est
alors bas c'est un peu glauque parce que
souvent ce sont des femmes qui sont
battus ce sont des étudiants qui n'ont
pas beaucoup d'argent les chambres elles
font à peine 5 mètres carrés ça tu morts
ouais donc ouais ça assez je sais pas
c'était pas top
là vous êtes caché dans le palais de la
femme vous voulez plus vous montrez
suite est ce qui s'est passé vous
reprenez pas contact avec la prod2 de
john deere haute et vous commencez à
être hôtesse la nuit dans des bars près
des champs elysées bonjour habillé tout
en noir avec les cheveux coupés à la
garçonne pour être sûr que personne ne
nous reconnaissent et là bas j'ai repris
confiance en moi parce que les gens les
clients tout monde était sympa vous en
sortez quand même c'est assez bien parce
que vous auriez pu rester maintenant
vous revenez avec french beauty donc est
un long métrage pour nommer un peu
décalé quand même non ouais et alors
appris et le documentaire sur canal qui
s'appelle ali donc et un documentaire
sur votre vie et puis vous allez bosser
sur la chaîne xxl vous faites une
émission qui s'appelle xxl xx e l
l es kim amiens villette
et donc fini c'est comme quoi la vie est
un vernis de scrabble parce que ça fait
des points
vous finissez par donner une interwiew
cahiers du cinéma comme quoi tout arrive
dans laquelle vous dites je voudrais
être un sex symbol mois la lilliputienne
avec des petits seins je voulais être
une pin up
ouais je suis toujours pas mais bon
c'est pas une pin up j'me suis pas les
formes
moi je trouve très sexy d'années cet
adorable non non c'est vrai
garou tu trouves pas non non non non non
non avec ta nouvelle voie vous dites
vite le porno a répondu à une demande
d'affection de ma part pas forcément je
veux que j'étais des monnaies par un mec
est terriblement de confiance là quand
vous recevez 150 mails par jour de jean
qui dit je vous aime je te trouve belle
tu me fait marrer ouais bon en même
temps tu me fais pas aimer mais bon
c'est déjà ça non
ouais bah oui c'est un compliment bien
si un grand compliment ah bah ouais
surtout pour moi banc des non non mais
elle elle est touchante ton histoire et
tout changer oui parce qu'après bomba
besson flash sur elle dans un casting
chez europacorp vous faites banlieue 13
et puis voilà enfin ici j'aime bien que
vous allez continuer là j'espère bien je
croise les doigts pour je crois que la
meilleure façon de se connaître un peu
mieux d'amis ce serait de savoir ce que
vous pensez quand vous êtes tout seul on
va faire une interview monologue d'amis
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
vous levez le matin j'ai une sale gueule
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
qu'est-ce que je suis belle qu'est ce
que vous vous dites quand vous venez
comme ça sur un plateau de télé j'ai
envie de faire pipi
venez en fait bill non il est tard on
s'en faut moi j'ai envie de rachat
garanti elle met en jeu tourne on ne
peut pas attaquer un poteau venait là on
va pisser
non alors regardez pas ça va me bloquer
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
vous concentrez pour jouer je vais tout
donner
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
revoyez votre parcours
[ __ ] qu'est ce que vous vous dites
quand vous êtes énervé j'ai envie de
tout défoncer qu'est ce que vous dites
que vous avez envie d'abandonner courage
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
recevez pas de scénario et ben jambes et
mon agent mais qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand un mec vous demande de
coucher avec lui j'ai dit non mon corps
appartient un seul homme c'est celui que
j'ai épousé vous êtes très fidèle et lui
oui
qu'est ce que vous en savez magnéto
serge tout le temps avec donc je vois
pas à quel moment il pourra l'inquiète
pas hélas il a trouvé ce qu'il fallait à
la maison non non non non non il ya des
choses que je peux faire que lui qu'une
autre femme ne peut pas faire par
exemple
deux anciens est ce que tu peux les
faire monter la courbe
je peux mieux faire connaître à sion
minute par minute
[Musique]
avec denis
seule main
un bon soir alors vous êtes un fils 2
mais votre père ne s'appelle pas à
l'idée depardieu ou dutronc votre père
s'appelait zemmour
edgar zemmour et il était l'un des trois
frères zemour alors la fin des années 60
au début des années 80 les frères et
mourront régnait à paris sur le la
prostitution le jeu les cabarets
mais will i am zemmour a été abattu en
1975 par la police edgar votre père a
été tué dans son sommeil en 1983 année
qui voit également l'élimination de
gilbert zemmour voilà alors le 28
février 75 donc un accrochage violent
entre les policiers de l'antigang est là
et la bande de votre père au bar le tlm
votre oncle williams et est abattu et
votre père décide de vous mettre à
l'abri vous avec votre mère votre frein
à votre soeur en floride à miami voilà
vous avez quatre ans et vous comprenez
pas ce qui vous arrive non non non je
sais juste que on est parti là-bas un
que je commençais ma vie aux états unis
j'ai été à l'école là-bas toute ma vie
et j'étais un peu
à l'écart de tout ça je ne savais pas ce
qui se passait je savais juste que ont
bougé beaucoup et que et que c'était
souvent un peu tendu bah oui c'est tendu
parce que votre père n'est jamais là
évidemment il n'arrête pas de faire des
allers retours entre paris et miami pour
ses affaires votre mère se réfugie dans
l'alcool et vous dit j'ai toujours connu
ma mère ivre je l'aimé comme ça oui
c'est vrai que ma mère je les ai
toujours reconnues comme ça et je pense
comme n'importe quel enfant chez gelé
mais peu importe c'est votre mère voilà
ouais alors vos parents ils se bagarrent
a quand même c'est le baston quoi quand
votre père est là c'est violent c'est
pas parce que mon père et l'un est que
ces violences et jusque je pense que
quand
quand on pratique ce qu'ils pratiquaient
je pense que c'est c'est difficile de
retenir un peu sa colère quand on rentre
chez soi et qu'on voit que sa femme ait
été vrai que les enfants font un peu
n'importe quoi
je pense que c'est c'est pas très
agréable et voilà c'est ça parfois ça ça
se passait mal quoi alors pour oublier
les pleurs les cris les coups vous
réfugier dans la musique et vous
découvrez supertramp quincy dc led zep
de nac les créateurs de my sharona ou
voilà c'est votre votre jardin secret
quoi c'est celle là dedans que vous
essayez d'oublier le reste en fait
souvent quand ça se passait mal je
m'enferme dans ma chambre et où je
mettais la musique à bloc pour rien
entendre où j'essayais d'écrire vous
votre père si votre idole à ce moment là
c'est à dire que quand vous balader avec
lui tout le monde l'aiment tout le monde
le respecte il fait marrer les gens quoi
c'est un personnage truculent en fait
gare zemmour na waie jeu je pense
qu'encore une fois - moi j'ai pas le
même regard sur mon père que les gens
qui ont pu avoir
parce que c'était mon père comme
n'importe quel enfant encore une fois je
l'aimais tel qu'il est tel qu'il était
et je sais oui c'était un peu mon idole
et le jeu
je pensais que je pensais que les gens
l'aimaient beaucoup les gens l'écoutent
et les gens les gens l'adoré
l'entouré et puis c'était mon père je
vais alors ça devient invivable pour
pour vous pour votre frère et pour votre
soeur à la maison vos parents se
séparent votre mère est expédiée à paris
où elle est rejetée par là par le clan
en arrivant ma mère de toute façon n'a
jamais pris parti de de la famille elle
dit c'est ce qu'elle pensait et elle se
reconnaît pas et c'était pas un trop la
façon dont il faisait les choses
en plus de ça elle avait un problème
avec l'alcool et je pense que la famille
n'acceptait pas du tout serait en tous
les cas après la séparation de vos
parents le calme revient à la maison
votre père vit avec une autre femme il
recommence une autre vie et à ce moment
là il ya des histoires incroyables
c'est à dire par exemple un jour vous
suivait des cours de taekwondo et et le
prof devenu un coup de règle sur les
mains et qu'est ce qui fait votre père
il est venu et il est rentré à
l'interdît de joe hill a appelé le prof
et il a amené dans le bureau et il lui a
montré leurs fans il lui a dit que si
jamais me repêcher qu'elle aimerait donc
j'ai arrêté le taekwondo tant que ton
bac à 12
le mec j'ai dit c'est gentil allait
vraiment fait 6 passes en place il ya
deux ans il ya aussi une autre histoire
qui est extraordinaire c'est un jour il
y avait un restaurant que votre père
voulait fermer parce qu'il marchait pas
et vous allumer un feu à côté du
restaurant et qu'est-ce qui se passe
je suis rentré à l'intérieur pour dire
mon père que j'avais allumé un feu qui
m'avait un peu dépassé ouais il me dit
qu'on allait rentrer à la maison
et donc voilà en train la maison et le
restaurant un brûlé mais en fait ça
l'arrangé parce que ça marchait pas très
bien ce restaurant est donc là qui
précède chine vous connaissiez le métier
de votre père à l'époque non quand il
partait c'est papa est en voyage
d'affaires
mais vous savez rire et très silencieux
ouais hein vous saviez pas n'est pas de
gardes du corps de toute façon non ouais
mais qui est toujours un peu sur ses
gardes quand même ouais il avait des
yeux derrière la tête
il pouvait pas être surpris 1 et puis le
8 avril 1983 ce jour là vous allez au
cinéma vous dormez chez un copain et le
lendemain quand vous rentrez à la maison
donc à miami vous découvrez qu'on a
enlevé la la moquette et vous comprenez
que quelque chose de grave s'est passé
la maison est vite vous comprenez tout
de suite que votre père a été abattu
ouais ouais tu savais que c'était la fin
de quelque chose
j'ai senti un vide c'est quelqu'un qui
avait une présence extraordinaire et
donc le jour où il a été tué j'ai senti
que il y avait il n'y avait plus un oui
il a été assassiné la veille
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que la nuit suivante vous êtes dans
cette maison avec votre frère votre
frère à une carabine dans les mains et
il vous dit pousse toi ne reste pas dans
l'angle de la fenêtre parce qu'il y
avait quand même un risque bien que dans
ces milieux-là se pratique pas mais
enfin ils réclament un risque qu'après
le père les assassins continue avec le
reste de la famille alors après
l'enterrement à paris donc il ya tous
les photographes tout ça vous prenez
conscience de ce qui était votre père en
fait au moment de son enterrement un peu
un peu ouais là vous perdez complètement
pierre vous dites de 11 à 14 ans tout
s'est éteint dans ma tête je ne parlais
plus je n'existais plus c'était le noir
total tirent là vous avez une un moment
ça bascule quoi c'est à dire qu'après
l'assassinât de mon père j'ai été
rapatrié à paris où les gens se disputer
un peu pour des histoires légaux par
rapport à aux biens et à l'argent je
suis resté j'habitais avec mon oncle
gilbert et trois mois plus tard il s'est
fait assassiner
ouais donc j'ai commencé à prendre un
peu une espèce d'habitude de sentir que
les gens allaient disparaître assez
rapidement et que tout ce que je pouvais
penser avoir entre les mains en fait
jamais j'avais pas quoi ouais donc à
saison vous retourner aux états unis en
fait
et là vous commencez à vous défoncer à
prendre de la drogue à faire des
cambriolages c'est à dire vous tourner
mal vous faites six ans de six ans de
prison au total quoi disons avec des
entrées des sorties
ouais à partir de l'âge de 18 ans j'ai
fait ma première peine de prison de
toute façon à partir de l'âge de 18 ans
de toute façon j'ai été j'étais tout
seul
ouais je le laissais personne à côté de
moi je laissais personnes rentraient
dans ma vie je je je retournais un peu
toute cette histoire contre moi j'essaie
de me punir pour quelque chose qui
m'appartenait pas du tout ma première
peine de prison je pense ça a été plutôt
un soulagement puisque autre chose parce
que en fait ça m'a empêché de continuer
à me faire du mal
c'est vrai que la prison ça n'a pas été
facile en l'occurrence quand j'étais en
prison
première chose que j'ai fait c'est de
recommencer à écrire ouais il faisait
thème devenu écrivain public pour le
pour les autres oui ce qui s'est passé
c'est que aux états unis souvent dans
les cellules où on est à plusieurs dans
cette cellule en l'occurrence on était à
peu près à 40
il y a toujours un détenu qui est chargé
de régner sur les autres est en fait
cette personne là un soir ma vie en
train d'écrire venu à regarder ce que
j'étais en train de faire a trouvé ça
bien et m'a demandé si je pouvais écrire
des poèmes pour sa petite amie donc je
lui ai écrit un poème pour sa petite
amie lui a envoyé et elle a commencé à
venir le voir elle lui donnait de
l'argent lui apporter de l'argent et
donc il m'a demandé si je pouvais
continuer un coeur vert et on échange un
protégé et m'a donné à manger ainsi de
suite vous dites que vous retournez dans
ces prisons par exemple il faut faire
très attention ne pas dire quand est ce
qu'on va sortir parce que si on va
sortir dans pas longtemps
les mecs t'agresse pour que tu restes
toi avec eux en prison pour tu croupis
savais que mon prison pour pas que tu
t'en ailles ont vaincu l'équipe
ouais en fait n'importe quel détenu qui
rentre dans une prison en floride où
j'étais il n'y a pas assez de place en
fait c'est un les pressions sont un peu
surchargé donc ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de séparer les petites
peines avec les grosses peines donc tu
peux te retrouver dans une prison avec
quelqu'un qui va sortir en 2075
et cette personne là n'en a rien à
[ __ ] de toi ni de la loi ni des reines
et de commettre à notre morte ça veut
absolument rien dire pour donc s'ils
savent que vous avez l'opportunité de
sortir ça alors ça leur met un peu la
haine et envie de te garder avec eux ça
va systématiquement il ya quand même de
la solidarité c'est pas tous les gens ne
réagissent pas comme ça il ya très peu
de soleil 21 c'est pas tout le monde
sait que à la fin de la journée c'est
comme chacun pour soi en prison et les
les gens en prison qui était avec vous
savez que vous étiez le fils de gaz et
moi lors des états unis j'ai toujours eu
mon anonymat
ouais jamais été perçu comme le chis 2
et serait donc vous repartez vraiment à
0 vous vous mettez à la recherche de
votre mère et puis vous découvrez que
qu'elle est morte quoi ouais
la dernière fois que j'avais parlé avec
ma mère c'était quand j'étais en prison
fédérale et je l'avais eue au téléphone
elle était dans un hôpital et c'était la
dernière fois que je lui avais parlé
quand je suis revenu en france
j'ai quand j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches pour essayer de la retrouver
personne ne savait où elle était on
savait qu'elle était partie de l'hôpital
et on n'avait plus revu
donc j'ai commencé à aller à clichy où
elle habitait ouais à marcher dans la
rue faire faire les bars ou peut-être je
pense elle a trouvé les gens se
souvenaient d'elle mais elle avait pas
vu depuis un moment donc j'ai commencé à
faire les rues les bancs les trottoirs
si je voyais une femme par terre qui
ressemble peut-être un peu ma mère
j'allais vers cette personne mais je
n'ai pas trouvé comme ça en fait j'ai
été à la mairie je leur ai donné son nom
et sa date de naissance et m'ont donné
un acte de décès ouais et alors ce qui
est extraordinaire je trouve c'est que
grâce au rock'n'roll
vous arrivez à briser cette malédiction
se dire que tout ce qui tout votre
énergie
vous l'avez vous la mettez dans la
musique vous la mettez dans le rock
vous avez fait un premier album qui
s'appelle heavy duty barda qui était en
liaison d'ailleurs avec cette nuit vous
étiez avec votre frère en train
d'attendre dans cette dans cette chambre
le lendemain le 9 avril au lendemain de
la mort de votre père cc liée à ça ça
chauffe chez criminels report il ya un
morceau qui est le single qui s'appelle
aux maï maï par them
m
[Musique]
à le coller sur orlando et oui en
floride
oui non mais vous connaissez le monsieur
orlando le frère de dalida
non ils exigent le clip alors vous allez
regarder votre caméra je lui fis en
caméra magnéto ya le rouge magnéto serge
manito cherche
ouais
[Musique]
oh my my par zen excès de vie du
tiberium son premier album
alors vous avez voulu mettre quoi dans
cet album toute cette histoire tous les
je savais que temps que cet album serait
pas écrit je pourrai jamais passer à
autre chose
donc c'était important pour moi de de
l'enregistrer de l'écrire et déjà même
arrêter quoi mais pas c'est autre chose
de l'enfer d'autres j'espère d'albums -
le deuxième album est déjà en cours ils
savent bien il tombe bien j'ai écouté
tout l'album c'est très très bien ça va
mieux là je pense que je n'oublierai
jamais mais
je vivrai pas dedans non plus le reste
de ma vie quoi je pense que mon passé
fait partie de mon histoire je pense que
ma vie fait partie de ma musique que ma
musique fait partie de ma vie et que
j'ai rien à cacher quoi et depuis
longtemps parce qu'on nous parler de ta
vie de ta survie et la musique c'est là
elle était omniprésente quand même notre
avis ouais ouais ouais
d'ailleurs on a on en a pas parlé mais
quand j'ai monté un groupe quand j'étais
en prison avec d'autres détenus il y
avait une voie là c'est sarens et sen
littéralement c'était ça dans la salle
de musculation il y avait une une salle
de répétition où il y avait des
instruments de musique et personnes
l'avaient utilisé depuis très très
longtemps et quand je suis arrivé en
prison j'ai été pour commencer à faire
un peu de muscu et parce que c'était
quand même important mais j'ai vu cette
cette salle de répétition et j'ai
demandé si on pouvait l'utiliser ils
m'ont dit que si j'arrivais à trouver
d'autres musiciens dans le dans la
prison j'aurai le droit de l'utiliser
deux fois par semaine donc j'ai trouvé
un bassiste un batteur et un guitariste
ceux qui voulaient qui restent avant toi
les cordes de guitare ça va faire des
tatouages
voilà c'est ça est derrière je me suis
vu faire un tatouage avec une corde de
guitare pendant que j'étais en prison
c'est vrai était fier de ton père ouais
je suis fier de lui s'il ya une chose
qui m'a appris c'est que si tu fais
quelque chose fait la faune ne lui pas
du tout vrai que les frères zemour ils
étaient 3 donc ils sont arrivés de sétif
en algérie en 55 et ils sont devenu en
20 ans les cas ils doublaient du cycle 1
on les appelle les drucker à l'époque
merci m
l'album s'appelle et millions tonnes
d'aidé
car dans catherine 6 novembre au nouveau
casino de paris
18 novembre à 11h life et 17 décembre
tel du nord à paris voilà zen et mercy 4
ans
dieu dit domaine
[Musique]
au revoir garot à bientôt
oh
alors alors je voudrais que garou nous
disent au revoir avec sa nouvelle voie
et je vous remercie s'était encore
mobilisé je suis désolé pour ce soir
c'est pas grave
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'azur
le boulet et cet accent ridicule
ridicule trouve ça pas mal d'occasions
qu'est-ce qui la gare où il veut revenir
et dit qu'il a été maltraité viens
t'asseoir ya des filles qui arrivent
même mam ait eu le temps pendra
d'arenberg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant quoi c'est annulé passer à
autre chose
ah bon et maintenant vient warwick
chacun grégory basso
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait un important ensemble quoi un
site de cham un clip de charme n'est pas
avec moi et journée avec laeticia qu'on
a vu c'était donc le bachelor et des
ballons si c'est là que tous les gens
qui font la télé réalité en fait il faut
défier quoi bein de charme
quid de chahains film de charme c'est un
film qui passe sur m6 en deuxième partie
de semaine passée 1 min 46 les attend et
retient on voit les poêles ou pas dans
les normes
non on demande justement qui est
beaucoup de toile pour justement que ça
camoufle au cas où c'est peut-être
qu'ils jouaient dans la touffe ça dit
quelque chose dans ton corps arrivé dans
la touffeur 14 explique madani d'entre
vous connaissez vous vous êtes vus
contre une fois comme ça au cours d'un
tournage faisait un reportage en fait
ouais ouais je suis un reportage et où
il jouait photographe voilà jouer le
photographe et je me rappelle que les
filles venaient me voir en disant danis
topless passer de la crème la crème
pailleté et
lui regarder comme ça et que l on qui
pendait en gaule et 10 mois alors
désormais tu étais plus greg le
millionnaire mais est ce que tu es
toujours millionnaire toujours pas même
en roupies
non je suis comédien aurait tvo coll non
non il est comédien et ses séides et
comédien c'est pas un jeu ce coup ci
c'est toujours de ma gueule
d'ailleurs s'il affiche qui tienne oui
bonsoir bonsoir se bâtit comédien
dis-moi comment tu fais alors pour dire
ton texte sans dire oh [ __ ] à la fin
de chaque phrase qui figure tools est
assez facile en fait et je perds même
mon accent parfois sur scène apparemment
mais j'ai travaillé pour ça je me suis
enfermé pendant un mois avec gérard
winter qui était mon mentor et qui m'a
dit mon ami plein de cerveau qui m'a
fait un bourrage de crâne et j'ai
énormément galères et c'était vraiment
difficile parce que j'ai appris que la
comédie c'est un métier et ce métier
super dur qu'on ne s'improvise pas
comédien comme ça ils mènent maintenant
la plus grosse fierté c'est d'être sur
les planches tous les jours de jouer en
live au théâtre de trévise et de voir à
la fin du spectacle les gens nous faire
trois quatre voire cinq rappels tous les
soirs écuyers et puis sortir avec le
sourire jusqu'aux oreilles et ma plus
grande fierté c'est ce à quoi voilà
alors la pièce s'appelle qu'on tire bien
sûr les lapins on a déjà parlé ici mais
c'était pas encore toi qu'il
l'internaute et c'est une pièce écrite
et interprétée par gérard painter avec
mot de bouquets et toi donc que kirk
rider désormais alors c'est l'histoire
de la peinture de partout alors c'est
quoi le pitch l'histoire mais c'est
l'histoire d'un mec plutôt d'un groupe
de mecs qui rentrent de vacances d'une
croisière et qui se retrouve qu'on
essaie dans un aéroport avec une valise
de coqs qui leur appartiennent pas oui
hélas il est naturel il revient au galop
c'est pas un rôle de composition est
mais je vous rappelle que l'été que que
la pièce a été écrite pour moi elle
existait quand même donc ouais voilà
et en l'occurrence il ya des mafieux
colombien qui arrive qui commence à les
intimider qui meurent des balles perdues
des flics complètement psychopathe
du raid qui a qu'une envie c'est tirer
son coup avant de rentrer dans sa
caserne dans la creuse ayant un agent de
propreté qui finit un petit peu
sado-masochistes vois ça tu fais le flic
je fais deux flics je fais le flic
psychopathe l'agent du raid je joue le
rôle du mafieux je joue le rôle de
xavier un vendeur du clae le dealer
colombien lundi nombre de propos tk une
[ __ ] en faire nous voilà il paraît pas
ce qu'elle fit du bruit apparemment tu
connais orlando ouais je veux dire quand
magnéto écoute pas la rigueur mais
pourquoi parce qu'il exige le clip alors
le tir regarde ta caméra magnéto serge
c'était la bonne caméra
ce n'était pas la bonne came c'est celle
qu'elle rouge du secteur nouvelle
s'énerver la wii vas-y magnéto serge on
va pas vraiment piccina la fille aux
yeux revolver se sont plus patients
alors mettre la ville du port
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
immérité longuement tient bien sûr les
lapins de gerpinnes teurs hockey à de
trévise avec maud buquet et grégory
basso qui est notre invité ce soir voilà
c'est bien non oui je trouve ça
formidable
j'ai quand même plaisir je suis emballé
parce que je suis un petit peu au tac
excusez moi parce que ça me fait
vraiment ça me tenait à coeur de
commencer là dedans
gérard winter est venu vers moi m'a
proposé ça et il m'a tout appris et je
suis content qu'on m'ait donné la chance
d'être au théâtre tous les soirs et je
me régale quoi finalement
ben ouais mais finalement tu vois ça m'a
ouvert des portes mais voilà alors bon
il ya cette carrière de comédien qui est
quand même déjà assez extraordinaire tu
en conviendras laurent et oui ça sent le
molière
le plus extraordinaire tu crois pas si
le gardien tu veux pas si bien dire
le plus extraordinaire c'est que le 22
novembre grégory part à new york pour
les emmy awards emmy awards faut savoir
que c'est la récompense mondiale des
programmes de télévision et il se trouve
que greg le millionnaire voilà est
nominée aux emmy awards
c'est incroyable en revient toujours pas
croyant bah ça me fait plaisir en fait
puisqu'il me fait le plus plaisir c'est
qu'à la base c'est un concept américain
wayne qui a été adapté donc par la
france et depuis qu'ils ont vu les
images ils ont toujours vendu avec les
images française de grasse et que c'est
un processus un programme français qui
va représenter une chaîne américaine
sinon ça fait plaisir quand même ouais
et je pense que la plus fière de tout ce
angela llorente la productrice ça lui
fait plaisir et c'est une condition
c'est quand tu vas aller à new york tu
va visiter la maison blanche bien bravo
voilée s'est rendu fait par greg a
indiqué marjolaine avec ça tu es
convaincu alors dit moi non sérieusement
il ya un truc à new york quand même
selector studio tu es d'accord et je
j'ai commencé les cours acteur studio à
paris justement je sais que c'est pas de
la garderie strasberg c'est à new york
qu'il était dans le coup je crois qu'on
va faire une interview acteur studio
[Musique]
alors est ce que tu pourrais nous jouer
la peur la sobriété la colère du sahara
est une plaie non c'est pas mal tiré
oui c'est pas mal est ce que tu pourrais
jouer le millionnaire malheureux de ne
pas trouver la femme de sa vie
je trouve que les sentiments il passe le
gigolo joue le gigolo pauvres à un homme
qui dit je t'aime avec les yeux avec la
bgd
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux nous jouer l'homme
qui veut faire comprendre à une femme
qu'il avait là tout de suite maintenant
couturier n'était pas leur ego rit on
recommence à temps même s'il te plaît là
tu as joué l'homme qui vient de manger
de l'ail
ça n'a rien à voir non fait nous nous
fait nous le truc ça qui fait le
sérieusement ça les gêne apparemment je
vais me gêne pas du tout les comédiennes
comme toi enfin que je la mange
maintenant non pas que tu vas mange que
tu la regardes jeu ici c'est manger
[Rires]
alors maintenant on voit la chine où
l'acteur canam hard pas être pris au
sérieux
tu as vu la palette des mecs ça vu
l'appareil est ce que tu peux nous jouer
l'inquiétude de la star devant le voici
du lundi matin
vous jouez la fleur qui pousse à john
faire le tueur silencieux [ __ ] coûte
le tueur je le fais tous les soirs au
théâtre
alors viens me voir au théâtre de
trévise du mardi au samedi à 20h et
j'invite tout le monde à venir nous voir
parce que c'est vraiment marrant vous
allez vous éclater c'est une comédie à
mourir de rire
sérieusement faut venir ou pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille mélanie laurent
[Musique]
ça va j'ai pas l'air suis un peu tendu
c'est un peu ma première télé vraiment
eu peu de temps c'est grand pourquoi ah
oui pour détendre les nanas pas bon
avait pas il sait pas des tendres et la
haye ont franchement rappelle qu'il est
un peu lourd
et là je le trouve brillant je comprends
c'est jacques si si il y en a tant
rageant quand même bien alors mes z'amis
donc on vous a vu dans ce qui suit entre
deux rives de gérard depardieu embrassez
qui vous voudrez de michel blanc
snowboarder d'olias barco et aujourd'hui
vous êtes l affiche de le dernier jour
de rodolphe marconi avec nicole garcia
et gaspard ulliel et bruno todeschini
il faut vous détendre à montpellier en
plus vous êtes la musique c'est
[Musique]
d'ailleurs le pitch ah non c'est le
beach parce que c'est votre fiscalité le
pitch assez ma spécialité pendant les
fêtes de noël un jeune homme découvre un
lourd secret de famille
lequel maintenant si je le dis tu vas pu
voir le film et sa fille ni comment ah
ben si justement c'est après celle à la
fin d'accord un lourd secret de famille
deux points pillay a c'est tout ben
c'est tout si je le dis tu as plus
d'intérêt sera tout petit pic là bas
c'est un petit pic mais bien les médias
la chute quoi ah ouais on l'a dit non
non non non ne dit pas oui voilà qu'on
est planté quoi on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble magnéto serge
[Musique]
c'étaient les foules simon avait pris
car après tout refait surface tout est
dans l'ain
[Musique]
le dernier jour de rodolphe marconi en
salles le 3 novembre
non mais c'est vrai que c'est difficile
à expliquer parce que si je dis le truc
pas une histoire de vengeance là dedans
non non non alors vous êtes venu au
cinéma complètement par hasard en fait
un
vous êtes allés avec une copine sur le
tournage d'astérix une copine dont le
père était chef machiniste et vous fait
bronzer un peu à l'écart
et là vous retrouver dans un pot en auto
tune palois parce qu'elles sont là deux
par du arrive à bille en obélix ou vas
me le faire de drague sur la rixe avec
le ventre et tous et il vous dit vous
voulez faire du cinéma
mademoiselle tiens voilà un bout d'essai
et voilà non mais c'est incroyable quand
même non c'est un miracle c'est oui
c'est vrai beaucoup de chance surtout
que le lendemain et il a eu un accident
en moto et que moi j'avais hésité entre
venir le mercredi ou le samedi donc si
j'avais été un autre jour je l'aurai
voilà c'est le carnage et le lendemain
vous faites quand même votre bout
d'essai oui voilà les ici sont
catastrophiques vous vous êtes engagé
quand même encerclèrent j'avais
tellement trac que je me suis attraper
un fou rire nerveux et que j'ai pas pu
dire une ligne du texte que je
connaissais par coeur et je pleurais de
rire qui se termine évidemment en
grosses crises de larmes mais voilà donc
je suis sorti de là et j'ai dit à mon
père m'a tu vois je ferais jamais de
cinéma parce que je suis même pas
capable de dire une phrase qu'est-ce qui
vous a dit votre père m'a dit mais non
ils sont dans le métier vos parents mon
père est comédien et maintenant la
provenance
oui vous avez fait ceci est mon corps
avec rodolphe marconi c'est ça et vous
avez eu à tourner des scènes d'amour
non je trouvais ça un peu cher qu'il n'y
avait pas longtemps que vous aviez votre
premier amant et déjà vous étiez en
train de jouer des scènes d'amour c'est
vrai c'est vrai et vous dites qu'en fait
le comédien il n'existe pas quand on
fait une scène d'amour
non c'est pas ça c'est qu'en fait on
c'était une scène quand même
bon c'est vrai pour une première scène
d'amour elle était un petit peu je
devais m'en prenais contre un mur quand
même en fait
pas facile non et en fait ce qui est ce
qui est assez troublant c'est qu'on
ressent absolument rien ça on est juste
paralysé par le trac et voilà il assez
de passe très très vite et on a fait
genre de trois prises
tu sais tout et en fait ça passe vite et
c'est vachement bien c'était vachement
bien tu sais pas ah non c'était pas
vraiment bien parce que c'était non
c'est pas très agréable de toute façon
il est 7 heures du matin on n'a pas
spécialement envie de ça tu as eu du mal
toi au début ouais contre un mur aussi
non si harry et toi moi ça a été assez
difficile en fait est un grand timide
toi mais les gens ne savent pas je
désert comme saab deux jours je sui greg
le millionnaire en fait t'es vachement
ou césar je suis dur 2 partout c'est un
tendre mais vous ça marche pour vous non
très bien ouais bah vous êtes cette
affiche d'un film de jacques audiard
bientôt de jean marc barr en fait ça
mange bien non ça très bien c'est dû à
quoi
voir
les jeux aux dragons marconi
avec gaspard ulliel
là dedans à denis va
t
m
à pied
[Musique]
bonsoir anne nivat sept gros porteurs
correspondante de wes pense à moscou
vous collaborez à l'international et
road trip youn au new york times le
washington post
vous avez eu le prix albert londres en
2000 pour chienne de guerre chez fayard
et vous publié aujourd'hui lendemain de
guerre chez fayard alors votre bouquin
c'est pas une analyse géopolitique c'est
pas un pamphlet anti américains comme y
en a toutes les semaines dans cette
émission mais un long reportage sur le
terrain en afghanistan et en irak voile
alors pendant des mois vous avez vécu
avec les habitants de ces pays
comme quoi ah oui comme eux comme moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est vous l'avais dit
je n'ai pas envie d'écrire un énième
ouvrage sur ce que l'on sait nous ici en
occident de mon idée c'est plutôt qu'on
sait pas grand chose qu'il ya une espèce
de confusion qui règne de plus en plus
énorme
si je demande aujourd'hui au public
qu'est ce qui se passe en afghanistan
personne ne sait vraiment des vagues
sélection la semaine dernière mais c'est
tout en irak on sait qu'à des
décapitations des kidnappings moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'essayer de
comprendre comment ces gens nous voient
comment ils réagissent à cette à cette
guerre qu'on le ramener à 7 à cette
invasion alors on l'appelle libération
mais pour eux c'est plutôt une invasion
une occupation est de 2,2 me rendre
compte
moi je suis une éponge j'écoute ce qu'il
me dise j'essaye de rentrer dans leur
vie broncher parce que toute façon je
suis pas à l'hôtel en irak ni en
afghanistan où vivait avec eux vous
prenez pas l'avion vous prenez le bus en
flammes je ne prends pas l'avion parce
que je veux me rendre compte de la
difficulté de déplacement donc je me
je me transporte en taxi communautaire
il faut donc en afghanistan je mets une
burqa parce que la burqa pour moi c'est
extraordinaire pour moi femme
occidentale de passage c'est le meilleur
les déguisements je peux voir sans être
vu je peux prendre des notes sous la
burqa c'est génial bon évidemment pour
une femme afghane c'est tout à fait
différent
je mets une abaya noire qui est un voile
noir en irak
mais c'est une question d'abord de
discrétion je ne cache jamais que je
suis journaliste à mes interlocuteurs
mais je ne l'affichent pas non alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert grâce
à votre méthode d'immersion dans la
population
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert en
afghanistan les gens ne sont pas
contents les gens ne sont pas heureux
les gens considèrent que cette
libération est une invasion
les gens ne comprennent pas les avions
aujourd'hui sont confus il n'arrive pas
à comprendre ce que font les américains
chez eux combien de temps ils vont
rester et comment ils vont restaurer
c'est ici il pense la bac les américains
sont pas venus pour combattre les
talibans ou al-qaïda mais qui sont venus
pour l'or et l'uranium à mais tout le
monde sait que les américains ne
combattent pas les talibans et al qaïda
c'est très clair puisque les talibans
sont toujours là j'en ai rencontré très
facilement d'abord par hasard dans un
taxi communautaire j'allais vers ross
vers l'est vers les zones tribales où on
dit toujours que oussama ben laden peut
se cacher et tout d'un coup la voiture
s'arrête on les descend des montagnes et
arrivent des mecs
avec des kalachnikov des masques et je
me suis dit ça y est c'est eux et donc
est ce que je fais rien je me tais et le
chauffeur ouvre ouvre la vitre
simplement aucune parole n'était changé
le talib le tallec nous donne un tract
le chauffeur prend le tract et puis on
s'en va c'est tout il avait déjà disparu
ça qu'on était quand même très près
d'une caserne américaine qui vous dit
que l'état lève les les talibans se sont
rasé la barbe etc mais qui sont toujours
là bas vous dit par exemple que ces gens
là savent très bien où se cache le
mollah omar par exemple bien sûr ils
savent tous les talibans les locaux le
disent ils ont enlevé leurs tirs ben
leurs turbans et puis ils ont mis la
cravate ils sont là de toute façon les
américains fonctionne de la même façon
ils ont fait ils commettent les mêmes
erreurs en afghanistan et en irak ils
les répètent alors la première erreur
c'est la corruption c'est-à-dire il ils
essaient d'acheter il essaye de ne pas
ne pas combattre bien sûr parce que
quand on combat on perd des hommes
c'est ça la guerre mais c'est justement
ce qu'ils ne veulent pas que nous voyons
est ce que vous voyez les cercueils des
soldats américains revenir aux
etats-unis est-ce que vous voyez les
enterrements personne ne voit rien
interdiction de filmer c'est la même
chose d'ailleurs pour les russes en
tchétchénie
donc on ne voit rien c'est une guerre
propre sauf que c'est pas vrai la guerre
c'est pas propre la guerre c'est ça la
guerre c'est dégueulasse et les gens sur
le terrain le savent alors il ya une
chose que j'ai remarquée dans votre book
a en tous les cas c'est qu'en
afghanistan les jeunes ils veulent
partir en australie où ça extraordinaire
à tous égards n'a que ça fait rêver
absolument mais vous savez ce qui est
amusant c'est que les
les tous ces gens j'ai rencontré en
afghanistan comme en irak les jeunes ne
connaissent rien l'amérique
d'aujourd'hui alors ils connaissent les
soldats le mépris qu'ont aujourd'hui
soldats américains pour eux avec le m16
au bras et cetera le doigt sur la
gâchette constamment mais en même temps
ils ont tous envie d'avoir des
chaussures nike des d'avoir d'être
habillé en s et c est de regarder les
clips américains la télévision tous et
en tchétchénie c'est la même chose
donc c'est assez rassurant remarquer je
sais pas si c'est toujours mieux qu'ils
ont envie de regarder des clips à la
télé vous achetez des nike que faire la
guerre pour le djihad 1 je crois qu'ils
ont aussi envie de faire la guerre pour
le girardin qui choisissent c'est pas la
même que tu agis rencontré pas mal de
rebelles ou deux il ya des taleb
habillant dyke
ouais ouais alors il ya tout un tas de
personnages dans votre bouquin savez que
c'est une approche très différente des
grandes analyses comme ça il y en a qui
s'appelle bill alors lui rêve de se
marier par amour c'est un irakien et il
est un peu inquiète travailler pour l'
us army parce que bon il se dit quand
même qu'il va se faire flinguer est lui
aussi veut partir pour l'occident sur ce
qui est extraordinaire je trouve c'est
finalement tous ces gens là ils n'ont
qu'une envie c'est d'aller aux états
unis d'aller en europe surtout les
jeunes
oui effectivement mais on les comprends
parce que quand même ils ont envie quand
mais mal aujourd'hui en afghanistan en
iraq faut quand même pas
exagéré cc et il en même temps ils ne
nous comprennent pas et ils nous envient
alors la seule image qu'ils ont de nous
c'est évidemment à travers la télévision
quand je suis arrivé au kurdistan donc
en irak
la première nuit j'ai fait une entorse
admirer des habituels c'est à dire j'ai
été obligé d'aller à l'hôtel puisque le
mec qui devais m'attendre à la frontière
n'était pas là bref
donc j'étais à l'hôtel et dans l'hôtel
j'allume la télévision et pendant à peu
près cinq minutes je n'arrive pas à
trouver sur la télécommande une autre
chaîne qu'une chaîne pornographique
toutes les chaînes pornographiques dans
toutes les langues européennes etc donc
c'est pour vous dire que aujourd'hui en
irak tout le monde se précipite sur la
chaîne par satellite en afghanistan
c'est la même chose et ici ils ont donc
c'est cette image très biaisée de
l'occident comme nous on a une image à
rézé de effectivement et moi c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est que en fait les
gens moi j'y vais sans a priori dans ces
pays j'essaye de me le fait d'ailleurs
assez naturellement je me force pas
personne me forcer à aller dans ces pays
là ça m'intéresse je me je suis comme un
caméléon je m'adapte je suis rackyel en
irak afghanistan et mais eux me pose
finalement autant de questions sur moi
que je leur pose souvent les femmes par
exemple me demande comment il est
possible que mon mari m'autorise à me
déplacer sans lui dans un jeu vous pose
la question moi aussi alors d'abord je
suis obligé de lui expliquer que en
occident une femme ne demande pas
forcément l'autorisation à son mari pour
tous surtout pour faire son travail
vous êtes sages quand vous vous promenez
comme ça à voile mais attendez moi je
oui quand je suis très sage je suis pas
occupé non attendez je suis très obsédé
par la réalité des choses qui est très
complexe dans ces pays là donc je prends
des notes du matin jusqu'au soir je suis
très fatigué quand je me couche très tôt
parce qu'à pas l'électricité etc
et puis je dors avec les femmes parce
que c'est les femmes l'ensemble les
hommes ensemble en irak en afghanistan
ce que vous dites à votre mari sa à
votre mari est à vous et à tout le monde
avait des fois vous pouvez tomber quand
même sur un très beau livre au total m
d'ailleurs journée dans mon livre
vous avez peut-être lu le crb ce mais là
ils sont urbains les baisses mais là il
m'a beaucoup moins plus quand il a
enlevé son tir bon et que l'été a
regardé le turban alors non il ya un
personnage en revanche que très
inquiétant dans votre bouquin s'appelle
ali qui a 26 ans et qui coupait des
langues et des mains pour le compte de
ou die le 6 2 de saddam hussein et alors
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'il
coupait les langues dans la rue du temps
de saddam hussein et qu' il coupait les
langues au vu et su de tout le monde et
capri avait une ambulance qui venait
pour emmener ma fille à oui quand même
l'équipe donc lui le personnage extra et
ensuite l'ambulance pour faire en sorte
qu'ils aient pas trop de celle à qui on
coupe les langues la barre couper les
langues à ceux dont on n'entend voulais
pas qu'il parle et il y en avait
beaucoup et lui me raconte ça finalement
5000 jeunes un mec de 24 à 56 ans qui
maintenant essaye de refaire sa vie
alors bon il était un peu difficile de
le trouver de lui parler mais il n'a pas
envie que les américains sachent qu'il
est aujourd'hui mais j'ai même pas pu
parler chez lui parce que sa famille ne
sait pas ce qui fait loin lui faisait
partie des mecs ils sont habillés
en nike adidas par exemple et qui sépare
fumée pour venir me parler dans un
restaurant un peu anonyme et qui avait
du mage et pas senti de remords dans ce
qui me disaient mais il me disait j'ai
été obligé qu'est ce que vous auriez
ferme plein soit tous nous on était les
rois du monde sous sous sous sous les 2
fils adam feeney m'a dit toi
sérieusement les gens et dope sait pas
quand on regarde votre bouquin comme ça
on a l'impression qu'ils regrettent un
peu les régimes dictatoriaux c'est
terrible à dire je crois que si on leur
pose la question aujourd'hui aucun n'y
en eut en afghanistan en irak ne dirait
on veut retourner sous les taliban et on
veut retourner sous saddam et simplement
c'est assez humain 2 2 quand on a quand
quand on est dans un état de chaos comme
aujourd'hui comme c'est le cas en
afghanistan et en irak
quand on est perdu quand on a vécu ce
traumatisme de la libération parce que c
est un traumatisme nous c'est facile on
nous dit ils ont été libérés devrait
être content mais non ils sont pas
contents parce que c'est le bordel en
afghanistan comme en irak a rien ne
fonctionne
et donc la tendance c'est de dire eh
bien finalement on avait davantage de
sécurité sous saddam et on en avait
davantage soul et aliments ça je les
entends dire neutre et non de la reprise
il faut attendre tout ça viendra et nous
si en occident on est trop impatient à
vouloir imposer notre démocratie
je vais repartir le mais je vais pas
rester ici
alors qu'est ce que je fais ici c'est
trop c'est trop c'est trop simple c'est
trop safe oui et oui et puis c'est trop
tout est trop compréhensif moi j'aime
les endroits qui sont vraiment très
compliqué à comprendre très complexes
ces sociétés sont des sociétés en
transition nous on n'est pas en
transition et à la gauche à la droite
tout et vous connaissez tous d' avance
là bas c'est le bordel moi j'aime j'aime
ça je sais pas quoi faire d'autre c'est
tout bas les i alors merci anne nivat
l'homme
monsieur
[Musique]
non
ah ah
voici martin circus
bonsoir sort super martin circus
mesdames messieurs l'or pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas martin circus martin
circus c'est ça
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a
[Applaudissements]
palmade marierait mama mama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a fait
pavages érigé la veille chez lui mal
tu dis là bas je
ça va
m
ah ah
[Musique]
à l'ats martin circus
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il ya
un truc chez martin circus
si vous êtes fort en l'intro non mais
c'est vrai voilà alors donc il ya une
anthologie qui sort l'anthologie de
martin circus 42 titres de la grande
époque du groupe c sur combien d'années
ça commence fin 69 quand même ouais
c'est dommage que des versions partie
parce qu'il a connu l on ait des courbes
effet 121 option jusqu'en 85
ouais parce qu'après chacun va faire des
choses différentes
et puis on s'est quand même retrouvé en
2001 pour un tribut de toutes races tout
on a fait une version du social elle est
géniale la version bravo à huawei très
bien je la conseille la version d'
antisociale
alors donc c'est une initiative qui
t'appartient girard c'est à dire que ça
parfois énormes et dieu tu as dit je
vais je vais je vais retrouver les bancs
dans les cartons donc y avait encore des
trucs était là depuis depuis 30 ans
ouais c'est à dire que tout d'un coup on
s'est dit moi je me suis peut-être 10 à
un peu plus fort que nous mais en mai on
s'est dit quand même que il fallait
remettre tout ça à la lumière et que
personne n'avait finalement mis un petit
peu tout ce qu'on avait fait sur un
double cd donc j'ai fait sortir les
cartons de la maison de disques et puis
je dois dire que sincèrement ça a été un
grand moment d'émotion parce qu'il y
avait des bandes que j'ai en sortant
comme ça qu'ils n'avaient pas été
ouverte depuis trente ans et j'ai
reconnu les écritures de chaque sur les
étiquettes jarque d'écriture d'alain et
que tout suivant un grande émotion comme
la bonne version la version mauvaise qui
est rayé que c'est certain qu'un album
est vachement bien alors on retrouve
l'esprit des 70 avec cette espèce de non
conformisme de créativité qui avait à
l'époque quoi cette liberté honnêtement
on était totalement libre serre oui
effectivement il y avait personne au
dessus de 12 ce qui permettait de faire
beaucoup de bêtises beaucoup d'erreurs
ouais
et puis de temps en temps des trucs
mieux mais c'est vrai que je pense que
ce qui appartient à cette époque c'est
le c'est l'esprit de créativité et puis
il y aussi expérimentale parce que le
joueur décide d'enregistrer des klaxons
away surcroît vous mettiez pas les
samples à l'époque n'ont donc ils
veulent faire un break pour fléac sono
qui met les quatre coccinelle devant la
porte du studio est enregistrée on me
dit qu'à ce qu'on me refais mettre des
micros par l'ingénieur du son dans la
rue devant l'eca coccinelles et puis on
se met à accélérer et à faire une
partition de klaxon pour klaxons et
malheurs comme ça et voilà
n'existe plus là non ça vous fait mais
toujours rêver quand tu fais la possible
distribution des concerts de klaxons
s'était défoncés de temps et d'où vous
vient cette joie de vivre c'est un truc
qui vous est resté des années 70 je
pense qu'on est restée un petit peu
accrochés certains non mais c'est vrai
que des trucs à produire bien c'est vrai
que peut-être que ce qui distinguait
cette époque de maintenance et je pense
que ce groupe a peut-être prolonger un
petit peu notre adolescence et que moult
substance également et que maintenant
qu'on est plus calme on continue à être
sur la lancée tu m'as ses dents et c'est
très joyeux c'est vrai quand on écoute
l'album ça met de bonne humeur
ça c'est clair c'est vrai qu'à un côté
festif qui est ça qui a fait années 70
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à
l'écouter alors il est heureux de vous
retrouver j'imagine tout cela pour faire
la seule union la promo de cet album
alors vous vous souvenez sûrement quand
vous faites cette promo des bons moments
ensemble
on va voir les pires moments on va faire
l'interview le pire des martin l'autre
pire chanson
waouh moi je sais baptisé eagle un petit
coin qui sont le foie on n'a pas mis
votre performance sur scène les freins
le dijon le changement du show
comment s'est envolé de dire c'est ça ah
oui c'est vrai faire qu'on est plus vive
le total retour dans les loges tout
short rock tabac
après toi non mais bon on fuit j'étais
bien des français revient quand on
arrive sur scène avec un spectacle très
léché avec des costumes des lumières et
ses dix minutes on en envoie on envoie
la purée il se passe le rien du tout le
public est là comme ça donc
clin d'oeil on se regarde on retourne
dans les loges on balance tout un bazar
de tout on vient en t-shirt et jeans en
balance du rock à ce moment là les gens
comme voilà tu as compris
non mais c'est votre pire tourner une
covedette avec michel sardou
ah ouais ouais aller à l'époque où où
les gens parce que nous on était en
première partie on chantait 1h15 devant
michel sardou et c'était l'époque où il
était pour d'agrès alors il y avait des
cocktails molotov qui volait sur le
chapiteau et puis aussi quand on sortait
de l'hôtel nous on était il y avait des
panneaux avec way votre pire expérience
sexuelle avec des fans motori ce n'était
pas nous c'est un surnom qu'on a les
noms adresses sur nos on lui avait donné
un elle s'appelait boîte à outils
avancés elle faisait tout votre pire
cuite au non il ya trop c'est du mit den
en 70 oui avec stevie wonder
j'aimerais oui mais voilà où en est on
avait été dans le spectacle du midem
avec stevie wonder et ça s'est terminé
dans la chambre du martinez avec son
guitariste et moult tromblon en août
moult et c'est vrai que stevie wonder il
a pris la plus moche non le pire
engueulades nom lors des engueulades ça
a été ça a été carrément on a tous été
viré du groupe bonne foi ouais votre
pire passé à acheter les oui je m'en
souviens salut c'est quoi alors notre
pire passage télé c'est titi titi est
alors justement tout à l'heure tu as
passé les indiens du petit matin et
alors on devait passer chez j'ai lu que
c'était la première télé et alors ils
veulent y voler mais quoi j'ai eu il est
fort on va faire venir les aliens les
indiennes de la mer de sable
alors bon nous ta maison de disques
enchanté génial
alors nous on avait préparé à une tante
d'indiens sur le plateau de guy lux et
puis ti qui devait faire venir trois à
trois cavaliers indien sur le plateau
donc c'était fantastique et tout à 17h à
la répète tikis et ils sont où les
indices sommes pas là et ils sont jamais
arrivés et donc on s'est retrouvé comme
des imbéciles avec nos tentes d'un bien
au milieu du plateau de guy lux 100 100
chevaux sans rien et en plus la tante
s'est écroulé à quelle heure
martin circus l'anthologie
quarante deux titres
je hais
[Musique]
on passe au blind test
et pour la neige accueille ce soir
charles chine points
[Musique]
à
j'ai un feeling bonsoir ans le 10 de
charles schillings c'est même notre
cobac et on l'entendra tout à l'heure en
entendra un morceau pendant le générique
de fin voilà alors ce bla une thèse
c'est un spécial duo à charles c'est ça
il ya donc je veux deux noms ce soir je
veux le nom des deux interprètes puisque
ce sont des duos
donc c'est l'équipe de mélanie cher
mélanie contre l'équipe de dany chef
danny voilà alors d'un côté des musicos
c'est vrai donc ça va les aider de notre
côté irm laurent baffie qui est un
killer au blind test alors on commence
tout de suite charles morceau numéro un
à la nation
[Applaudissements]
le jura
tu sais pas
voilà merci charles donc bravo long mais
ça indépassable laurent baffie au bout
de trois mesures
il reconnaît dalida et alain delon
charles manso numéro 2
ce prêt
[Musique]
non
oh
au nom de tout effort en beatles ah
ouais un peu plus comme dalida
ouais un peu plus scandale il a bien
joué bien dit numéro trois charles
non
[Musique]
tibet
on continue sur le numéro 4 à l'essonne
[Musique]
oui
ouais
les deux sets
laurent banide
[Musique]
quel est le groupe de femmes qui avaient
créé ce morceau aux états unis dancing
in the street un demi point un demi
point pour l'équipe de dany que gérard
vient de remporter haut la main sa 1/2
mélange de distribuer des deux minutes à
raison
alors si j'ai bien admis en continu sur
michael jackson le soutenait louis
allain
la comédienne et bluesy
[Applaudissements]
il est
j'en conviens
oui
oh
oui surtout
bravo ma fille ça fait quatre points
pour l'équipe de mélanie bravo mélanie
et un point et demi pour l'équipe de
dany voilà on continue charles n'zogbia
tout ça
[Musique]
on continue charles gainsbourg
péripéties charlotte gainsbourg
16h15 mauvais départ
[Musique]
ouais là c'est dur là c'est dur la
terreur la assez dur sur l'a61 et demi
il a perdu une fois lundi
non mais là là là il va avoir du mal
vas-y charge
[Musique]
nous savions seniors
waouh
non
[Musique]
ou pas
mais a reconnu l'entrée de l'année
dernière beyoncé et jay-z bravo on
continue non
marché américain
qui sait
[Musique]
c'est un
c'est à deux ennemis bravo tu veux
marquer un point d'accès pas mais c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas mal on
continue shah gas bourg de la faune
[Musique]
thouaré
toi
vue satellite
moi je suis
on continue là il va pas trouver
peut-être quand même j'espère j'espère
vas-y choisi joue
[Musique]
non
mais je
mais l'année en poney
catherine géant blanc dit catherine
barma et catherine barma et j'ai envie
que suprême
attention continue 8 à 3 me en continu
chat facebook
oui
[Applaudissements]
d'écouter tout le monde a mis trois gars
ce jour là tu va dégoûter tout le monde
de jouer je te jure là c'est pas moi
qu'il l'ait nice et ses chars et ma
femme non mais vraiment tu va dégoûter
tout le monde qu'on joue et arrête
arrête toi maintenant j'ai encore le
poisson on en arrive au chacun pour sa
gueule donc si la fin du par équipes 1
attention c'est le banco charles pidjot
[Musique]
mais super banco j'espère qu'il n'a pas
trouvé merde
m
cité
[Applaudissements]
alors laurent on a marqué un gérard en a
marqué un l'ultra banco charles
schilling
streisand garros fin de la semaine
non
oh
donc j'en rends ma fille deux géants
blanc 1
nous arrivons mégabanques haut et celui
ou celle qui va remporter le méga banco
sera la star de cette soirée c'est très
difficile
charles schillings à toi il excelle
[Musique]
des faits
kern c'est la réponse tient bien et
mathieu wen
le choix
et moi
suite
il
mais
patrick de fille monroe
ça vient d'une histoire je vais pas
je
thomas
il
non
en cas d'issue tout en collant ma fille
l'or noir comme le gagnant avant quand
ce titre un petit rappel la télé c'est
quoi quand michel drucker était entré à
la halle à ce qu'on appelle ou rtf en
64b que des vieux téléviseur en je fais
chier tout le monde d'accord ok on plie
ont pris c'était tout le monde en parle
et en magie le coffret intégral
jacques dutronc 66 76 les années vol est
toujours [ __ ] dure le gabriel aghion
avec gendarmes auront michèle laroque et
dany boon
michel drucker les 40 ans de la te c'est
lundi à 20h50 sur france 2
caroline
père starzyk cuivre consacré à tariq
ramadan c'est chez grasset garou l'album
s'appelle reviens il est en tournée et
il sera les 9 10 12 13 novembre au
zénith de paris
tannis bellissimo bonsoir banlieue 13 de
pierre morel
sortie le 10 novembre plus la bo du
banlieue 13 j'aime l'album s'appelle
heavy duty berden il est en concert le 6
novembre au nouveau casino à paris le 18
novembre à la house of live à paris et
le 17 décembre à l'hôtel du nord à paris
voilà
grégory basso 30 ya bien sûr les lapins
de gerpinnes teurs avec m'occuper c'est
au théâtre trévise voilà l'ennemi
le dernier jour de rodolphe marconi avec
nicole garcia et gaspard ulliel
sortie le 20 novembre anne nivat
lendemain de guerre chez fayard
martin circus merci l'album sa belle
anthologie et charges fixes le dj
doublette est là
il s'appelle notes correctes voilà
l'album s'appelle no cry voilà alors
amnistie internationale appelle à une
mobilisation samedi 6 novembre à 14
heures dans les jardins du trocadéro à
paris pour les petits szczesny voilà
c'était tout le monde en parle
merci d'abord écrit avec tous rendez
vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bach
[Musique]
bon
les
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
voir
allez
[Musique]